Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 7.
Die Internetbeschalung mit Frank und Fefe.
Das ist eine Boulevard-Internetbeschalung, muss man dazu sagen.
Ja, ich mein, das ist doch evident, oder?
Ist evident. Wenn wir schon ein radio machen, dann muss es Boulevard sein.
Aber natürlich.
Ja, es wird ja langsam so Winter, wie man anhand des Wetters sehen kann. Und wie jedes Jahr, wenn es kalt wird, haben wir natürlich ein, unser Lieblingsthema. Nämlich, wo kommt denn eigentlich die Wärme aus der Wand her? Und die Wärme in Deutschland kommt aus der Wand meistens von Gazprom. Und dann haben wir unser zweites Thema, nämlich ein Lieblingsthema, nämlich bizarre Selbstmorde.
Wir sollten vielleicht als Vorwarnung vorher schicken, diese Sendung wird ein bisschen verschwörungstheoretischer als vorherige Sendung. Selbstverständlich nach wie vor alles vollständig auf Faktenbasis, aber dazwischen sind auch ein paar offene Fragen, die wir thematisieren werden.
Irgendjemand muss ja diese offenen Fragen thematisieren, nicht wahr? Weil sonst haben wir irgendwie...
Für uns ist es ja langweilig. Im Übrigen ist es gerade draußen dunkel und langweilig und kalt und deswegen müssen wir zumindest drin ein bisschen Wärme machen. Ja, aber was ist denn, wenn es Winter wird, dann kommen immer die Russen und drehen am Gass an und haben plötzlich technische Probleme.
Sie sind ja doch immer sehr kreativ. Entweder sie haben wirklich technische Probleme oder sie sagen, es gibt da so noch kleine Unstimmigkeiten bei den Verträgen, die mal schnell geklärt werden müssen.
Also historisch gesehen ist es nicht unbedingt Schuld der Russen gewesen, sondern die pipeline der Russen geht ja durch die Pufferstaaten, die nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg eigentlich dafür dienen sollten, die westlichen Armeen fernzuhalten. Aber dann, nach dem Mauerfall, er dafür gesorgt haben, dass von dem reingepumpten Öl und Gas im Westen nicht die bezahlte Menge ankam, sondern nur so eine geringfügige Abweichung von der eingespeistem Menge kam.
Diese kleinen Inventurdifferenzen sind ja durchaus traditionell, also historisch betrachtet normal in der Gegend. Zu DDR-Zeiten war es so, dass in Polen gingen so viele Züge verloren mit Kram, der aus der Sowjetin und die DDR sollte, dass sie einen Extra-Fährtermin gebaut haben in Kleipeda, was heute im Baltikum liegt, um einen Umweg zu haben für Zeug, was ein bisschen wertvoller ist und was bitte nicht verloren gehen sollte.
Sachen, von denen wichtig war, dass sie ankamen, die wurden verschifft?
Die wurden dann tatsächlich lieber in einen Eisenbahnwaggons verschifft.
Heute baut man halt Pipelines für die Sachen, die wichtig sind und ankommen sollen.
Zum Beispiel Erdgas, ja. Diese Pipeline, in die es da geht, ist die sogenannte North Stream Pipeline. Die geht unter der Ostsee lang und verteilt sich dann so in den Gefilden. Ich war am Wochenende draußen auf dem Land und lustigerweise geht da so eine Abzweigpipeline von dieser North Stream Pipeline lang. Dann habe ich mir mal angeguckt, wie so eine Pipeline eigentlich aussieht. Also ich werde da noch einen Blog drüber schreiben.
Wo kommt die eigentlich raus?
Schöne Fotos gemacht. Die kommt da so in der Nähe von Greifswald raus, aus dem Meer und verteilt sich dann von da aus weiter. Interessant ist, wie groß so eine Pipeline ist. Man hat ja auch schwer so eine Vorstellung.
Es gibt so Bilder, da könntest du auch mit dem Auto durchfahren.
So groß ist die nicht. Also die Pipeline, die sie da verlegen, diese Gas-Pipeline, die euch dem Schwede hochgeht, geht mir so ungefähr bis zur Schulter. Also hat so 1,50 ungefähr Durchmesser. Und was mich ja speziell interessiert, ist, wie dick ist denn eigentlich der Stahl in so einer Pipeline? Der ist tatsächlich ungefähr so dick wie so ein Euro-Stück. Also etwa drei Zentimeter Stahl.
Also da lohnt es sich ja auch Rohstoffdiebstahl.
Deswegen verbuddeln sie die auch. Na gut, wer klaut schon eine volle Erdgas-Pipeline? Das fällt irgendwie auf.
Die Leute klauen auch Kupferbahnen über Landleitungen.
Klauen auf dem Strom, das ist ja gut. Aber das Problem ist, bei so einer Kupferbahnen-Überleitung, da kannst du halt im Zweifel dafür sorgen, dass du den Strom abschaltest, aber bei so einer Gas-Pipeline, da fällt das schon auf. Und ich glaube, so streng kannst du dich an dein Rauchverbot nicht halten, wenn du da die Sachen aus dieser Pipeline rausflext.
Vor allem musst du sie aufschweißen.
Das sieht sehr beeindruckend aus. Verbuddelt wird die interessanterweise von einer italienischen Firma, die offensichtlich den Contract gewonnen hat, diesen Abschnitt der Pipeline zu verbuddeln. Und ja, da gibt es auch so einen Webseinpaar, die wir verlinken werden noch.
Das ist auch historisch ausgesprochen spannend. Mir fallen spontan zwei Dokumentarsendungen ein, die ich da mal geguckt habe. Die eine war über die DDR, die nämlich damals auch eine Pipeline gelegt hat, unter widrigen Umständen, durch unschönes Gelände. Da haben sie dann ein paar von den Ingenieuren interviewt und die meinten, technisch gesehen hat es überhaupt keinen Sinn gemacht, aber es sollte eben den Russen bewiesen werden, dass die Deutschen das können. Und da haben sie dann halt unglaubliche Ressourcenmengen draufgepumpt, damit da diese Pipeline stattfindet.
Es war wohl so, dass es eine neue Pipeline geben sollte, weil DDR halt auch mehr Ötö gebrauchte. Und die Russen haben damals gemeint, ja, das ist ja schöner, wir haben gerade keine Kohle mehr dafür. Also wir haben keine Tierressourcen. Und wer denn eine Pipeline wollt, dann baut sie euch doch. Und dann haben sie halt tatsächlich angefangen, diese Pipeline zu bauen. Interessant war, dass das im Osten so ein bisschen wie der wilde Westen war. Also zur Durchbau-Pipeline gehen, haben halt viele Leute gemacht, die es halt auch nicht mehr ausgehalten haben oder die halt einfach, denen das alles zu eng wurde oder die weit ausgefressen hatten und erst mal für eine Weile weg mussten oder wollten.
So wie die fremden legionen, ja?
So ein bisschen, ja. Also natürlich nicht ganz so krass, aber es war halt schon hart. Also es war halt so, dass sie, naja, Sibirien und so, also mit irgendwie Mücken und Frost und irgendwie dem ganzen Scheiß. Und die Arbeitsbedingungen waren halt echt hart. Also es war halt so teilweise mit Zelten im Winter und so. Also war nicht so angenehm.
Also auch der DDR-Streckenabschnitt davon war wirklich unangenehm. Also in dem Film zeigen sie das Gelände und da gab es also den ganzen Sommer über im Grunde einen Schlamm Erdrutsch nach dem anderen und die ganzen Geräte hielten nicht und es war ein Death March.
Und darüber hat Mückenschwärme, dass die Luft grau wurde.
Also keine spaßige Angelegenheit.
Nee, aber es war ein interessanter Benchmark, wie eng die Leute sich gefühlt haben hier im Osten, dass sie so was als, sozusagen so im Wildwest mal ein bisschen anders und gucken die Leute nicht so genau hin, ein bisschen Freiheit.
Konnte man sich das anders überlegen, wenn man da hingegangen ist und festgestellt hat, wie scheiße das war?
Das war wohl nicht so einfach. Du hast dich wohl verpflichtet. Also es war dann halt so rund sechs Monate, da war die Mindestvertragsdauer oder so. Und manche waren halt teilweise jahrelang, die haben sich dann halt dran gewöhnt an dieses Leben da und haben dann halt durchgezogen. Einige von denen sind mittlerweile übrigens auch in der Ölindustrie wieder gelandet. Naja, klar, ich meine, du brauchst ja da auch. Also das Equipment, mit dem sie diese Pipelines legen, ist echt spezialisiert. Also der Status, den man da beobachten konnten, die Fotos sind dann in meinem Blog. Die rollen offensichtlich die Pipeline in so grob zusammengeschweißt in den Graben rein. Also die schweißen die sozusagen oben so mal auf Länge zusammen.
Ja, und so würde ich das auch machen, oder?
Aber das ist dann offensichtlich noch nicht die finale Dichtigkeitsschweißung, sondern die rollen die dann rein und dann haben, heben sie die mit so Gurten an. Das sieht so ein bisschen aus, so wie überdimensionierte Möbelgurte. Heben sie dann so ein ganzes 20 Meter langes Segment an, so dass die biegt sich dann so ein bisschen die Pipeline. Also du musst dir vorstellen, wie schwer die ist, wenn du das mit Wasser benutzt hast, und dann gehen sie die Schweißnähte nochmal durch und machen Dichtigkeitsprüfungen und den ganzen Kram.
Das Lustige ist auch, wie sie die Schweißnähte durchgehen und dass sie für ihre Maintenance nicht Leute an der Pipeline entlangschicken, sondern haben die kleinen Roboter, die sie durch die Pipeline durchschicken. Also das ist echt Hightech, was die da tun. Und da gibt es also auch eine sehr spannende und ich weiß nicht, ob ich die wiederfinde, wenn ich die jetzt suche, aber da konnte man mal sehen, wie so ein Roboter aussieht. Das ist natürlich besonders gut nachvollziehbar bei Unterwasser-Pipelines, wo das überhaupt nicht in Frage kommt, wenn jemand hierher schickt. Aber sie haben diese Technologie eben, dass sie da so einen kleinen, nicht ganz autonomen, der ist schon ferngesteuert, aber sie haben halt so einen Roboter, der von der Größe her genau passt und der eben sich dann da durchschlängelt und der mit Ultraschall und irgendwie Hightech-Methoden nach Materialermüddung sucht. Das ist schon sehr spannend auch.
Also die, die sie da verbuddeln, die verbuddeln die halt, die liegt dann so zwei Meter tief im Boden. Also es ist dann schon anstrengend, da willst du genau wissen, wo du buddeln musst.
Ja, wie waren wir bei den Pipelines? Eigentlich sind wir darauf gekommen wegen dieser Ukraine-Meldung, ne?
Eigentlich sind wir darauf gekommen wegen diesem merkwürdigen Selbstmord von diesem Gastbraumen-Manager bei Moskau, der erst sich als hochrangiger Mitarbeiter der Finanzabteilung oder sowas gemeldet wurde von Riana Wosti.
War das nicht auch so ein klarer Fall von Selbstmord?
Ja, der war so klarer Fall, mit in seinem Auto, mit einem Knebel im Mund und erschossen mit der Pistole, die ihm vom...
Der kassacherische Präsidenten?...
der Kassacher Präsidenten geschenkt wurde. Das war schon ziemlich weit oben auf unserer Rankingliste von bizarren Selbstmorden. Die werden doch schon seit einigen Jahren pflegen. Das war auf jeden Fall ein sehr klarer Fall von Selbstmord.
Ich meine, das kann ich auch nachvollziehen, würde ich auch machen, oder? Wenn ich mich erschieße, würde ich erst mal knebeln.
Ja.
Das liegt nahe.
Und um zu zeigen, dass ich mich auch selbst erschossen habe, würde ich so eine Spezialpistole nehmen, natürlich. Damit da keine Zweifel offenbleiben.
Ja, möglicherweise wollte er damit auch noch eine Messe schicken auf, keine Ahnung.
An die Kasachen meinst du?
Ich weiß nicht, was Kasachen oder was Tajikistan ist.
Ich glaube, es war die Kasachen.
Ich hab's vergessen. Na gut, wir können die Riegerner Russen noch mal verlegen, ja.
Das war ein diplomatisches Element, war da auch drin.
Es ist so ein lustiger Sport, dass die Russen sich immer noch so diplomatisch gerne Waffen schenken. Also, dass Putin verschenkt wurde an so diesen ganzen Jungs da unten. Also diese Regierung da in diesen Ländern immer noch gerne so versilberte und vergoldete Kalaschnikows aus Spezialeinfertigung.
Das ist doch aber auch cool, oder? Ich meine, das hat doch, finde ich, cooler als wenn du so ein...
Das macht aber einen höllen Diplomatenärger. Stell dir vor, du musst da mit einer Kriegswaffe wieder zurück nach Europa.
Ach na ja, komm. Das ist doch alles diplomatengepäckt.
Diplomatengepäck, naja. Aber deklarieren mussten sie, glaube ich, trotzdem. Na ja.
Ja, aber das, also das finde ich schon wieder lustig. Ich meine, dieses ganze Diplomatengepäck, das ist ja sowieso... Also es gibt ja, ich habe mal so eine nordkoreadokumentation gesehen und die haben also so einen riesigen Schrein gebaut für die ganzen diplomatischen Geschenke.
Einen Schrein?
Die haben einen richtig fetten Schrein gebaut und das ist quasi der Beweis, dass Kim Jong-il auch im Ausland der Gottkönig ist, ist, dass ihm so viele Sachen geschenkt werden. Das heißt, die Bevölkerung kann dahin gehen und sich das angucken und da haben sie einfach alles einmal hingestellt, was dem... Und das sind wirklich bizare Sachen irgendwie so. Schnupftabakdosen aus Elfenbeinen, also unglaublich. Und das ist also einer der offiziellen Touristen-Stops. Wenn du da als Tourist nach Nordkorea kommst, dann haben die da so eine Tour für dich und da ist das dabei. Und da wirst du da stundenlang durchgeleitet und kannst dir angucken, wie toll auch das Ausland Kim Jong-il fühlt.
Ob sich da von jemanden Spaß draus macht und dann ihm besonders vnordige Geschenke schenken?
Das kann schon sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob die da noch einen Spezialkeller haben, der so mit dir sagen kann, wer weiß. Aber ich stelle mir das schon witzig vor, wenn du so ein Staatschef bist. Ich meine, auch die westlichen Staatschefs haben ja Probleme, dass sie das dann auch nicht privat annehmen dürfen, sondern das muss dann, wenn Wulf das Geschenk kriegt, muss er das in Bellevue ausstellen. Was macht die damit? Das kannst du nicht privat in deiner Wohnung hinstellen, sondern das ist halt ein Staatsgeschenk. Also selbst wenn das irgendwas Schönes ist, dann kannst du das auch nicht mitnehmen. Insofern irgendwann gibt es bestimmt auch ein Lagerproblem. Ich weiß nicht, wie die das machen.
Vielleicht versteigern sie es dann für Charity oder so? Nein, das geht nicht. Das stimmt, das können sie auch nicht machen. Na gut, aber vielleicht darf man sich ja wenigstens mal so in die Arktflinte borgen, wenn es schön ist oder so. Das kann ja sein. Naja, um nochmal zu Gazprom zurückzukommen. Eine der interessanteren Aspekte gerade ist, dass die Polen hängt ja genau wie Deutschland an der russischen Gasnadel. Das heißt, dass sie haben einen größeren Teil ihres Energiebedarfs. Kriegen sie aus russischem Erdgas.
Und die nutzen immer den Sommer, um Verhandlungen mit den Russen zu führen?
Das ist ja durchaus clever, aber dann so langsam...
Die Russen, die brauchen dann im Sommer haben sie immer... Irgendetwas hält sie immer auf und dann fertig wird es immer erst so kurz, bevor es richtig scheiße kalt wird. So wenn es echt dringend wird, dann sind auch plötzlich die Europäer immer zur konzession bereit.
Also ich glaube, so Gaspowermanager könnten eigentlich so im Venture-Capital-Business auch ganz prima überleben.
Das glaube ich auch.
Weil die können also dieses irgendwie verhandeln bis zum letzten Augenblick, bis irgendwie gerade so noch die letzte Gehaltsrechnung noch so rausgeht.
Aber das ist auch generell ein russischer Tugend, oder? Wenn du diese Iran-Verhandlung ansiehst. Ich meine, die sind doch Großmeister darin, so wirklich 20 Jahre zu brauchen, um so ein scheiß Atomkraftwerk-Deal zu unterzeichnen.
Ja, naja, gut, ja.
Gut, da geht es auch nicht um den Iran, weil ich meine, also das ist schon...
Ja gut, also die situation bei den Polen ist gerade, sie haben halt irgendwie darüber verhandelt, dass sie halt mehr Erdgas brauchen und haben einen Rahmenvertrag abgeschlossen mit Gazprom.
Durchaus günstigen wohl.
Um halt an dieses Erdgas zu einigermaßen vernünftigen konditionen zu kommen. Und nun von völlig unerwarteter Seite funkt in die EU dazwischen, die gerne möchte, dass die Pipelines, die Gazprom und die staatliche polnische Ölgesellschaft PG Neg durch Polen haben, Picknick, dass die einem Regulierer unterworfen werden. Also was die da tun.
Einen unabhängigen Regulierer.
Einen unabhängigen Regulierer. Was die also tun wollen, ist das tun, was sie hier in Deutschland immer wieder verhindern, nämlich dass die Stromnetze einem unabhängig und für alle zum Durchleiten problemlos möglich geöffnet werden, wollen sie halt dafür das Gasnetz auch durchsetzen. Die Polen sind natürlich einigermaßen angewidert davon, weil sie ja eigentlich gerade ihren Deal mit Gazprom unterdacht haben. Und dazu gehört nun mal dieser Adventure Deal.
Na die Polen sind vor allem sauer, weil jetzt halt gerade Winter wird.
Genau, jetzt wird gerade Winter. Deswegen haben die jetzt offensichtlich gerade erstmal den Vertrag unterschrieben gesagt, naja, dann gucken wir mal, was mit der EU da wird. Aber wir brauchen jetzt erstmal das Gas irgendwie.
Ihr könnt uns ja eine Strafe verhängen, so nach dem Motto, wir machen es jetzt, wir müssen jetzt hier heizen. So, scheiß auf eure großen Designs, jetzt wird hier geheizt.
Ja, also, ich meine, die EU da macht natürlich durchaus einen ernsthaften Hintergrund. Die wollen natürlich, dass die Pipelines, die aus dem Osten kommen, nicht von den Leuten beherrscht werden, die das Erdgas haben, um sicherzustellen, dass sie zumindest noch wesentlich die option haben, welche von den russischen Erdgasfirmen sie sich aussuchen, um halt ihr Erdgas zu kriegen.
Anbandling nennt sich das bei uns.
Genau, Anbandling ist das Stichwort.
Eigentlich ist ja Anbandling erfunden worden, um unsere Energiemafia aufzubrechen. Weil wir haben das Problem, zum Beispiel wenn hier eine stürmische Nacht ist, wo der Energiebedarf gering ist und wo die Windparks alle bis zum Anschlag Strom liefern könnten, da haben wir im deutschen, im europäischen Strombörsenmarkt haben wir teilweise null Preise für Strom.
Negativpreise teilweise gar nicht.
Negativpreise, also das heißt, da gibt es dann mehr Strom als gebraucht wird und wir haben keine 50. Speichertechnologie. Und weil das auch an stürmischen Tagen droht, haben die Strommafia sich dann so Dinge überlegt, wie dass sie da halt nur eine dünne Leitung hinlegt zu dem Strom, zu dem Windkraftpark und dann sagt, ja tut uns leid, aber mehr können wir gar nicht einspeisen, weil sonst platzt die Leitung. Also das ist durchaus ein politisches Instrument, um deine eigene Monopolsicherung zu betreiben, diese Leitungsbesitzer und deswegen, das war eigentlich die Idee hinter dem Anbandlegen, dass wir mal unsere Strompreise senken, indem wir der Mafia die Durchleitmöglichkeiten wegnehmen, damit da jemand anders mit Geld verdient. Und das ist halt fundamental gescheitert, was unter anderem daran liegt, dass die Strommafia bei uns, also die ganzen Konzerne, werden im wesentlichen Sitzender lauter abgehalftert, da ist SPD-Politiker drin, die halt nach ihrer Politkarriere da, ja also neben den Lotto-Gesellschaften, sind das immer die Energiekonzerne, wo die dann noch ihr Zubrot verdienen und die haben halt noch connections zum Nachwuchs und deswegen wird aus diesen Gesetzen nie irgendwas. Na und jetzt die ersten, bei denen sie wirklich mal offenbaren, ein echten Anlaufunternehmen, sind die Russen, das entbehrt schon nicht einer gewissen Ironie.
Naja, wir sehen ja zum Beispiel in der Ukraine, da gibt es ja gerade eine ähnliche situation, inzwischen haben die Russen versucht, das gesamte Gasnetz, also das Leitungsnetz zu kaufen.
Die haben auch den Energieversorger komplett gekauft oder nicht? War da nicht sowas?
Die haben einen Energieversorger komplett gekauft, aber es gibt ja mehr. Den staatlichen? Die wollten halt ja auch das komplette Netz mitkaufen natürlich.
Das war eigentlich auch die Idee.
So und jetzt stellt sich da der ukrainische Präsident quer, weil er sagt, lass mal lieber einen Joint-Venture machen, weil wir wollen halt da noch nicht unsere Souveränität so vollständig aufgeben. Das ist interessant, also wir müssen mal gucken, was da die eigentlichen Hintergründe sind, weil bisher waren wir ja davon ausgegangen, dass nach den letzten Wahlen die Russen die Ukraine wieder sauber in der Tasche haben. Das heißt also, wenn die sich jetzt so ein bisschen borstig zeigen, dann hat das entweder innenpolitische Gründe da in der Ukraine, dass sie sich also nicht so sehr als Lakaien der Russen präsentieren können oder noch irgendwas anderes Interessantes.
Das ist ja nur eine Gelddruckmaschine auch. Insofern ist das politisch durchaus sinnvoll.
Größere Teile ihres nationaleinkommens, das ja aus Durchleitungsgebühren besteht.
Ja, also es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn aus ukrainischer Sicht, da die Russen einfach durchleiten zu lassen. Das war im Grunde zu erwarten, dass die Ukraine sich querstellt, aber es sah eben lange Zeit nicht so aus, weil da die pro-russlern-fraktion die Wahl gewonnen hat.
Die Russen haben ja auch immer so einen ganz seltsamen Humor, wie er neulich unser Bundespräsident feststellte, als er bei einem Besuch irgendwo in der russischen Provinz in seinem Salat einen sehr frischen Salat bekommen hatte.
Da kroch noch der Regenwurm raus.
Der Regenwurm befand, der den Weg durchs Internet fand in Form eines Fotos.
Und der lustigerweise geblockt von einem der russischen Zuständigen da.
Von dem russischen Gouverneur, der daraufhin gleich mal mitgefeuert und nicht gleich bedroht wurde.
Der hat es bei Twitter rausgehauen und das war irgendwie innerhalb von einer halben Stunde wieder weg, aber es gab halt irgendwelche Leute, die haben das gemirroert und wieder so, ist im Internet klar, wenn man da einfach was weg tut, dann so, naja.
Ja, so ein Regenwurf im Teller ist natürlich auch eine interessante Ansage. Auch in der Türkei, wo der Wulf neulich war.
Am Moment, der Russenhumor dazu war, dass der also auch auf Twitter nicht nur das Bild gebracht hat, sondern dazuschrieb, na dann sehen sie mal, wie frisch bei uns der Salat ist und unbehandelt. So, dass es halt bio-salat nach dem Motto war. Also die haben schon sehr eigenen Humor, die Russen. Eigentlich ist das eine schöne Sache auch.
Sehr hübsch, ja. Sehr eignet Humor hatten auch die Türken, als der Wolf da gerade war. Da war bei seiner Rede nur das halbe Parlament anwesend.
Und nicht mal die Ministerriege war vollständig angetreten. Da fehlte auch die Hälfte. Also das ist schon ein diplomatischer Affront, wenn da ein ausländischer Präsident anreist und vor dem Parlament eine Rede hält, dann ist man da eigentlich anwesend. Das war der stinkige Finger der Türkei, dass sie da nicht anwesend waren. Obwohl Wolf nun gerade einer der wenigen ist, um nicht zu sagen der einzige in der CDU, der gerade so ein bisschen versöhnliche Töne anspricht. Was ja eigentlich auch witzig ist, der letzte Mann, bei dem man Rückgrat erwartet, hätte in der CDU einen Unerwohlten. Und ausgerechnet der ist der einzige, der jetzt sagt, der Islam ist Teil Deutschlands und kriegt auch gleich von allen Seiten auf die Fresse dafür.
Unglaublich. Islam kommen wir später nochmal dazu. Bei Russland gibt es ja noch diese schöne Geschichte, wo sie Putin im Interview gefragt haben, wie es denn jetzt mit dem demonstrationsrecht sei. Und da hat er diesen schönen Spruch gebracht, also bei angemeldeten demonstrationen gar kein Problem, aber nicht angemeldete demonstrationen, da gibt es dann schon mal den Knüppel auf den Kopf.
Das ist ja auch bei uns der Goldstandard, selbst bei angemeldeten demonstrationen.
Wir hatten ja letztes Mal über die Polizeigewalt bei Stuttgart 21 und den strukturellen Hintergrund berichtet. Und da gibt es ja einige interessante Anmerkungen, die wir dazu noch machen müssen sozusagen als Follow-up.
Also erstmal, die Presseberichterstattung hat uns fast vollumfänglich zugestimmt. Also die Sachen, die danach rausgekommen sind, haben uns alle gedeckt. Diese Teams, die wir angesprochen haben, diese Greif-Teams waren im Einsatz. Das hat auch die Polizei gesagt. Und es gibt sogar, was sehr selten ist, eine Bestätigung, dass es eben diesen Provokateur gab. Der Mann, der man auf dem einen Video gesehen hat von der Polizei wie er. Und nur da hat man ihn gesehen, wie er Pfefferspray auf die Polizei sprüht. Der ist danach gesichtet worden, wie er hinter den Polizeilinien verschwand. Und ohne geprügelt zu werden oder rausgegriffen, sondern von sich aus. Also das war...
Der wurde in Sicherheit gebracht.
Der wurde in Sicherheit gebracht, damit er nicht von den Demonstranten eben beweistgesichert wird.
Also es ist insofern interessant, als dass das eigentlich sehr selten passiert, dass so eine Agent-Provokat-Hörnummern auffliegen. Leider ist es momentan noch so, dass die Mainstream-Presse da noch nicht so richtig drüber berichtet. Ich hoffe, das passiert noch. Weil natürlich die argumentation, die da jetzt gekommen ist, gerade vonseiten der CDU, dass irgendwie die Demonstranten ja mit der Gewalt angefangen hätten, der gleichen Dinge mehr, halt völlig ad absurdum führt.
Also das Lustige ist, dass es gab eine Bestätigung in der Springerpresse. Von allen Presseorganen am wenigsten erwartet hätte man es von der Springerpresse. Aber ausgerechnet die haben einen nicht näher genannten Polizisten gefragt. Das ist der Hamburger Morgenpost, war das glaube ich?
Oder Amblat?
Oder Amblat, also irgendwas, Springerpresse in Hamburg jedenfalls. Und der hat gesagt, ja, also er wisse ja von seinem Kollegenkreis, dass wie es ja üblich sei bei Demos, auch bei dieser Demo Provokateure im Einsatz gewesen seien, damit man besser zugreifen kann. Und leider haben sie da keinen Namen ran geschrieben, aber darauf kam ein, wie ist der, Moa von der Gewerkschaft der Polizei und hat also jetzt nicht Provokateure bestätigt, aber ähnliche Sachen gemacht, also starke Kritik geäußert am Vorgehen der Polizei.
Insofern hat er bestätigt diese Geschichte, dass die die Anweisung zu diesem exorbitanten Gewalteinsatz von sich nicht vom Polizeipräsidenten kam. Die muss halt von aus der politischen Ebene gekommen sein, hat er bestätigt.
Also er hat sogar gesagt, er kennt den Polizeipräsidenten und findet es ja sehr ehrenhaft, dass der jetzt die Verantwortung übernimmt, aber er kann am wenigsten dafür. Also dass dieser Polizeipräsident, auf den ja alle sofort irgendwie gezeigt haben, so der ist schuld, dass der jetzt auch noch quasi sich schützend vor seine Politiker stellt, das lässt ja schon mal tief blicken.
Und daraufhin haben sie aber diesen Gewerkschafts- der-Polizeitypen- Erstmal in den Innen-Dienst gesetzt, genau so.
Und das, ich mein, um zu sagen, was das für eine krasse sanktion ist, das haben sie auch gemacht mit dem Freiheit statt Angst-Typen, oder? Und zwar nachdem wir da jahrelang Druck ausgeübt haben, ist der dann auch irgendwann in den Innen-Dienst versetzt worden. Also das ist so das Übelste, was sie tun können, quasi, vor disziplinarischem Rausschmiss. Was so selten ist, ist da überhaupt im Fall bekannt. Also da muss man schon echt jemand erschießen.
Ja, muss man schon suchen.
Und selbst dann, ja, also es gab ja gerade diese, wie hieß der Tennessee Eisenberg Geschichte, wo ja nun jemand erschossen wurde.
Mit zwölf Schüssen.
Mit zwölf Schüssen. Und das war dann ein klarer Fall vor Notwehr und das ULG hat die Klage abgelehnt. Also da, selbst wenn man jemand erschießt, ist nicht klar, dass man rausfliegt bei der Polizei.
Naja, also insofern...
Also wir fühlen uns jedenfalls bestätigt.
Da bleibt auf jeden Fall noch einiges zu tun, was irgendwie die Transparenz bei uns ausübern der Staatsgewalt angeht. Wir hoffen mal, dass die diskussion um die Kennzeichnungspflicht da nicht versandet wieder, sondern dass sie irgendwie mal vielleicht bis zum nächsten ersten Mal oder so durchgeht.
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Interessant wäre auch noch die Geschichte mit dem Wasserwerfer. Wie war es zuerst? Der neue Sanftwasserwerfer?
Ja, das hat das Bildblock ausgegraben. Eine super Sache. Und zwar gab es da ein Bild von Oktober 2009, wo sie gesagt haben, die Polizei kriegt einen neuen Wasserwerfer. Der hat jetzt noch mehr Wumms und da kann während des Fahrens schießen und hat noch mehr Gewalt. Also da wurde so...
Etwas umgekehrt.
Nein, von Oktober 2009 haben sie halt gesagt, das ist irgendwie der tolle neue Gewaltwasserwerfer. Und dann haben sie jetzt nach S21 haben sie dasselbe Bild, dasselben Wasserwerfers genommen. Und da war die Meldung halt das Gegenteil, nämlich das ist jetzt der neue Sanftwasserwerfer. Also das war schon sehr witzig, das werden wir, glaube ich, mal bei der Fnord News Show einbauen, weil das eine sehr schöne visuelle Sache war.
Ja, wir waren gerade noch bei Provokateuren.
Die gibt es nicht nur bei der Polizei, die gibt es auch in der Politik.
Die gibt es auch in der Politik. Also eine der Dinge, die wir in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen ja noch relativ intensiv betrachtet haben, ist diese unsägliche Sendung, wie heißt die? Die Tatortinternet auf RTL 2, wo sich die Gattin unseres Bundespräsidenten doch sehr weit aus dem Fenster hängt. Und also was da passiert ist, kennt sicher nicht mittlerweile jeder, also da werden halt getreu dem amerikanischen Vorbild, was da Catch a Predator hieß, Leute provoziert in Chats, wo jemand im Chat so tut, als wenn er ein 13-jähriges Mädel wäre. Und dann wird halt nach Männern gesucht, die versuchen mit der anzubandeln und die werden dann halt mit einem Fernsehteam konfrontiert, das sie dann befragt. Nun stellt sich so langsam raus, dass diese Bande, die diese produktion macht, schon seit einiger Zeit unterwegs ist, und sich da Frau Gutenberg offensichtlich in einigermaßen unfühle Gesellschaft begeben hat. Weiß nicht, ob sie davon wusste oder nicht. Also wir haben dann mal so ein bisschen geguckt, und dann kamen so ein paar Sachen raus. Dieser Uwe Nagel, also einer der Mitproduzenten.
Nee, das ist der Moderator.
Der Moderator.
Und der war ursprünglich, war der mal Münchner Polizeipräsident, hat sich in seiner Amtszeit von einem Trickbetrüger auf wirklich billigste Art und Weise verarschen lassen. Also der war schon damals nicht gut. Und später ist er dann von von Ronald Schill, diesem, diesem Lord Order, in der Schill-Regierung in Hamburg. Im Schill-Senat war er der Innenminister und hat da auch Prüge Polizei sozusagen vorangetrieben. Wir müssen hier mal für Ordnung sorgen. Und inzwischen ist er bei einer Firma namens Prevent.
Hast du einen privaten Schnüffeldienst?
Na, also eigentlich weiß nicht, was die eigentlich als, nee, die sagen nicht, dass sie eine Detektei sind. Aber wir haben mal nach denen gegoogelt und da kam halt raus, dass die bei der HSH Nordbank, die ja ansonsten eher durch Bailout und grobe Inkompetenz in Sachen Geldverwaltung aufgefallen sind, da gab es auch einen wunderbaren Skandal von der Weile, in deren, ich glaube, New Yorker Büro war es, bei der Wall Street. Da haben die nämlich einen Mitarbeiter rausgeekelt, indem sie auf deren Computer Kinderpornos gefunden haben, und von dem dann rauskam, dass sie die selbst dahingeplantet haben. Und die Security-Firma, die die dann gefunden hat, also es ist nicht klar, ob die die da auch hingetan haben, aber in dem Kontext tauchte halt diese Prävent AG auf. Und das ist schon, also ja, das ist jetzt nicht hängen geblieben, aber der Zusammenhang existiert halt. Und dieser Uwe Nagel macht jetzt Moderator bei Tatort Internet und erklärt uns allen, wie schlimm das Internet ist.
Dann haben wir noch mal so ein bisschen weiter recherchiert. Wir bekommen ja beim Klub immer regelmäßig Anfragen von allen möglichen obskuren Leuten. Und da haben wir im Jahr 2005 tatsächlich mal eine Anfrage bekommen von jemand, der sagte, dass er mit dieser Frau Kraft Schöning, die damals mit einer Initiative namens NetKids unterwegs war, zusammenarbeitet und die– ich zitiere mal den wesentlichen Teil– würde der CCC in einer gemeinsamen aktion NetKids, dem LK und dem TV, also dem Fernsehen, in die Seite lizinet.de eindringen und die Datenunsicherheit simulieren.
Also nicht eine richtige Lücke zeigen, sondern wir sollten eigentlich– hätte es jetzt völlig gereicht, wenn wir so tun, als wäre das unsicher.
Genau, und was die wollten, war halt, also lizinet.de ist ein Chat, der betrieben wird von Kindern- und Jugendpsychologen, das ist ein von der Bundesregierung gefördertes Projekt. Also wir kennen die auch ganz gut und haben mit denen auch schon mal gelegentlich Kontakt gehabt. Und die sind, ja, das ist eigentlich der, sagen wir mal, eines der wenigen Lichtblicke in diesem ganzen Kinder- und Jugendinternetbereich. Und ausgerechnet die wollten die hacken, um, also gehackt haben, um dann das– um eine Quote zu machen. zu simulieren, dass sich da auch nur irgendwie Leute, Pädophile rumtreiben. Was die halt offensichtlich nicht wussten, ist, dass die Chats da bei lizzy.net halt wirklich intensivst betreut werden von professionellen Psychologen, die halt einfach schon ein Auge darauf haben, dass da irgendwie sich genau solche Leute da nicht rumtreiben.
Das wäre ja eigentlich schon sehr witzig gewesen, wenn die sich gegenseitig in die Falle gelaufen wären. Weil lizzy.net hätte dann im Zweifelsfall Deniability gehabt und diese TV-Fuzzies.
Ja gut, also das war halt damals 2005 mit, also was man sieht ist, die betreiben dieses Spiel schon seit langer Zeit und jetzt haben sie offensichtlich mal Erfolg.
Und es geht eben auch nicht um tatsächlich Pädophile, sondern das ist Einschaltquote, ganz klar.
Also Einschaltquote und politische Propaganda, also anders kann man das mittlerweile nicht mehr sehen.
Möchten gerne Gesetze auf den Weg bringen, das ist alles Law and Order, weil das verkauft sich eben gut im Fernsehen.
Also das ist halt so ein klassischer Fall von irgendwie dem Versuch, Fox-Sons zu inszenieren, der eigentlich an den Kernproblemen vorbeigeht. Also diese Empörung da über Gewalt gegen Kinder, die da, man muss schon sagen, inszeniert wird.
Inzwischen ist es sogar Springer zu blöde, oder?
Und den RTL2-Zuschauer auch, also die Einschaltquoten von denen sind unter Durchschnitt und sinken wohl weiter.
Unter RTL2-Durchschnitt, also nicht nur irgendwie unter Durchschnitt, sondern unter RTL2-Durchschnitt. Und das lässt ja tief blicken, denn ansonsten, was haben die sonst so für Sendungen? Irgendwann ist das irgendwie, Bauer sucht Frauen, so das Scheiß. Unglaublich!
Ich hab keinen Scherz, ich weiß es nicht.
Also ich hab keine RTL2 in meinem Fernsehsetup. Ich gucke immer irgendwie öffentlich-rechtlich. Aber also unter RTL2-Durchschnitt lässt wirklich tief blicken.
Ja gut, also wie gesagt, also ein bisschen merkwürdig, dass sich die Gattin unseres Bundespräsidenten mit solchen Leuten assoziiert. Also da ist doch wohl einiges im Argen so. Also ich hoffe mal, dass die Sendung dann auch langsam abgesetzt wird und wir uns zu wesentlichen Problemen zuwenden können.
Also eigentlich fände ich es nicht schlecht, wenn die weiter läuft und die Gutenberg weiter damit assoziiert wird, denn das kann eigentlich nur... Also auf lange Sicht habe ich nämlich so ein bisschen Resthoffnung, dass uns das den Herrn Gutenberg vom Hals erhält, weißt du, wenn er in diesen Sumpf damit reingezogen wird von den Krawallmachern, von wegen... Ich weiß natürlich nicht, also von mir aus, ob die da sind oder nicht, spielt ja im Grunde keine Rolle. Die einzigen, die da hingucken, sind offenbar Journalisten, die da drüber ran, danach so.
Den Eindruck könnte man gewinnen.
Das Presseecho war echt enorm und das war alles... Alle haben nur gemeckert, wie scheiße diese Sendung ist. Das war echt auffallend so. Ich habe nicht einen gefunden, der gesagt hat, oh, endlich kümmert sich mal einer. So, niemand ist darauf reingefallen. Und alle so, boah, was für eine widerliche Propaganda.
Naja, also diese Inszenierung, die die da gerade fahren mit dem Paul Gutenberg als neuer Bundeskanzlerkandidaten, ist schon so ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Die haben ja nichts anderes. Die CDU kann einem ja auch irgendwie leiten.
Die haben nicht mal einen eigenen Kandidaten, sondern sie müssen sich... Hier wäre das eigentlich in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik nicht so oft passiert, dass die CDU so verzweifelt war, dass sie am Ende einen CSU-Kandidaten jetzt featuren, weil irgendwie die Marke ihnen an Farblosigkeit doch zu farblos geworden ist oder so.
Ich glaube, es liegt nicht an der Farblosigkeit, sondern dass die Merkel sich hinter S21 gestellt hat. Und da fällt gerade dem einen oder anderen auf, dass das auch ein Boomerang werden könnte.
Naja, also wenn man sich so anguckt, was die da gerade tun, diese kombination von Anti-Islam-Hetze und irgendwie, wir müssen jetzt mal S21 durchprügeln, ist der der Versuch, wieder zu einem Lagerwahlkampf zu kommen. Also zu sagen, jetzt vorbei mit, wir haben zwei SPDs in diesem Land.
Keine Inhalte mehr, sondern es geht hier um...
Nee, Inhalte gab es ja schon vorher nicht. Was es vorher nicht gab, war überhaupt ein Kontrast.
Na, vorher gab es schon Inhalte, da haben sie ja behauptet, sie hätten hier Reformen, die sie durchführen wollten. Der Höhepunkt war doch, dass Schäuble jetzt vor zwei Tagen der Presse erklärt hat, er könne sich ja an keine andere Regierung erinnern, die innerhalb von einem Jahr so viele Erfolge vorzuweisen habe, wo ich so dachte, so, was? Die Hotel-Ges-Steuer? Oder was? Ich meine, was haben die denn überhaupt gemacht?
Ich weiß nicht, mir fällt auch nicht so viel ein. Ich meine, wahrscheinlich gab es irgendwas, aber es muss wahrscheinlich im Bereich Forstwirtschaft passiert sein oder so.
Unglaublich jedenfalls. Also dieser Gutenberg, der ist ja bisher auch nur aufgefallen. Durch diese Bundeswehr-Bilder, hast du die gesehen?
Ja, aber der interessante Punkt ist, was nicht so sehr aufgefallen ist, in einer FAZ haben sie die Rede gedruckt, die sozusagen parallel zu Wolf gehalten hat, zum 3. Oktober, also zum nationalfeiertag. Und die war nicht mal so richtig doof. Also die war halt stront konservativ, so kann man niemandem vorhalten.
Also schon doof, aber nicht irgendwie.
Zumindest hat er sich mal um so ein paar Themen wie z.B. Demografie gekümmert und klar gesagt, dass wir eine Einwanderung brauchen, weil sonst haben wir niemanden mehr, der uns in 20 Jahren Exoskelette wartet. Das hat er natürlich nicht gesagt.
Ui, aber Moment, das ist ja für CSU schon durchaus ein pensionär.
Insofern scheint sich da so ein bisschen so ein Punkt herauszubilden, dass offensichtlich der etwas liberalere Teil der CDU sich bei Gutenberg sammelt und die anderen Spinner, die halt irgendwie die Merkel-Islamismus-Verprügler, um dein Wort zusammenzufassen, auf der anderen Seite. Also keine Ahnung, wie das so ist.
Das sind ja eigentlich Schüler-Verprügler. Der Islam ist ja eher so eine neue Sache. Eigentlich geht es die Kernpolitik der Merkel, das ist ja Schüler-Demos verprügeln.
Stimmt, Schüler-Verprügeln ist eigentlich die Kernkompetenz. Aber na gut, womit wir eigentlich schon bei diesem Thema sind, sind genau diese Anti-Islam-Tenure, die da in allen möglichen Ecken und Enden hochkommen.
Wir hatten ja den Wilders in der Sendung fünf, war das, oder? Fünf oder vier? Die neuen Rechten. Und das war an sich schon spannend, aber da gibt es noch mehr. Wir haben noch ein bisschen hinterher recherchiert. Und eine Sache, die hier so noch gar nicht angekommen ist, ist, wer den eigentlich finanziert, den Wilders. Denn der ist ja eigentlich so ein One-Man-Programm. Die Partei ist wie der Schild damals. Ohne den gibt es die Partei eigentlich nicht. Da gibt es zwar noch ein paar funktionäre, aber keiner, der irgendwie an die Öffentlichkeit tritt und unter dem sich jemand was vorstellen kann. Und da braucht man ja schon Mittel für. Das kann man eigentlich einfach so los treten. Da reicht es nicht populist zu sein. Und wenn man da mal hinterher googelt, trifft man auf sehr bizarre Verschwörungseiten, in denen dann Sachen stehen, wie das es eine Vereinigung namens Likud Holland gibt. Also die niederländische version von Likud, das ist die größte Partei Israels. rechtsnational, das ist die Nitaniao-Partei. Likud Niederlande ist keine Partei, sondern ist so eine Pro-Israel, wie soll ich sagen, Pressure Group, würde man sagen. Und die haben dem im Wesentlichen wohl den Wahlkampf finanziert. Genaus weiß man nichts, denn es gibt in den Niederlanden kein Accounting für Wahlspenden. Also wenn man da der Partei was spendet, dann kann die Partei das irgendwie in die Bücher tun und offenlegen, aber muss sie nicht. Das heißt, wenn man sich jetzt fragt, wer hat da eigentlich den Wahlkampf finanziert, das ist quasi Glücksfall, wenn überhaupt was rauskommt.
Also im Wesentlichen ist es unklar.
Und bei Wilders ist eben rausgekommen, dass dem seine Wahl von Pro-Israel-Gruppen finanziert wurde und es gab eine völlig geile Nordmeldung, dass der Inlandsgeheimdienst der Holländer, also deren Äquivalent zu unserem Verfassungsschutz, die haben natürlich auch das Mandat, Extremisten zu überwachen und zu sehen, ob die gefährlich sind und Wilders war natürlich sofort auf deren Radar und die wollten den auch überwachen, aber es ging nicht, weil der seine wichtigen strategischen Meetings in der israelischen Botschaft durchgeführt hat. Und da können sie natürlich nicht hin, weil das aus naheliegenden Gründen. Und selbst wenn sie hin kämen, den Israelis traue ich durchaus zu, dass sie da Gegenmaßnahmen ergreifen. Aber jedenfalls das allein ist ja schon ein unglaublicher Fnord und das konnten wir eigentlich auch gar nicht glauben und haben dann mal ein bisschen hinterher geklickt und es hat sich ja so bestätigt. Es ist sogar so, dass der Inlandsgeheimdienst der Holländer das offiziell gesagt hat. Die haben gesagt, wir haben versucht, den Wilders abzulauschen, aber wir konnten nicht, weil der in die israelische Botschaft gegangen ist. Und das muss man sich ja mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Stellt euch mal vor, der Verfassungsschutz geht an die Presse und sagt, wir wollten ja die NPD belauschen, aber das ging nicht, weil die in der, was weiß ich, südafrikanischen Botschaft waren. Also das ist ja schon mal echt ein Hammer, diese Nachricht. Und weil wir das nicht glauben konnten, haben wir mal ein bisschen rumgefragt bei Holländern und das ist also tatsächlich auch bekannt und stimmt. Also das ist mehrfach bestätigt.
Also die...
Das ist schon ein Hammer. Da haben wir uns natürlich gefragt, warte mal, wenn die Israelis den Wilders finanzieren, das würde erklären, warum er mal gegen Islam ist, aber nicht generell gegen, also er könnte ja auch gegen Judentum sein. Ist er aber nicht. Im Gegenteil, er ist sehr offen pro Judentum. Es geht sogar so weit, dass es auch deutsche proisraelische Vereinigungen gibt, die voll pro Wilders sind, deutsche zionisten. Wir werden da noch, ich glaube, ein, zwei Links haben wir da, die wir zum Material geben können. Also das ist auch ein Exportprodukt, will ich damit sagen. Der ist nicht nur eine niederländische Sache, sondern das ist kein Zufall, dass der auf Tournee geht. Und der hat ja hier in Berlin neulich auch, war der auf Tournee, und hat hier sich von PI News rumzeigen lassen und hat auch versucht, hier Politiker zu treffen, unter größten Security-Sachen natürlich, weil sie ja damit rechnen mussten, dass es da irgendwelche Anschläge gibt, und weil es sowieso Todesdrohungen gegen den gibt, und der lebt nur noch mit Bodyguards und so.
Die Einführungsrede hier in Berlin hat doch ein israelischer Knesset-Abgeordneter gehalten.
Das ist schon krass.
Also es stellt sich für mich so ein bisschen so dar, als könnte das so einer der großen politischen Hex des Jahrzehnts sein. Das nämlich die, also wenn man sich so anguckt, die Israelis sind ja doch relativ gut darin, politische Einschätzungen ja weit im Voraus zu treffen und entsprechend zu handeln. Und wenn man sich so die Krise anguckt, wie es sich so entwickelt hat.
Na die Timeline, genau. Wenn man mal guckt, das ging los mit Haider, der war so einer der ersten, die hier angefangen haben, Ausländerhitze zu befinden.
Ich meine, Haider ist ja durchaus noch eher aus der Ecke, sagen wir mal so ein bisschen so klassische nationalkonservative.
Eben, eben. Aber es ist so, dass bekannt geworden ist, dass der Generalsekretär von dem Haider ein Mossad-Agent war. Also die Israels haben gesehen, da gibt es eine Strömung, haben den natürlich versucht zu belauschen. Und naja, es gibt auch Gerüchte, dass ein Autounfall nicht von der Leidenschaft gefunden hat, aber da gibt es keine Belege für. Aber jedenfalls aus Sicht Israels ist das ja völlig eine sinnvolle reaktion, wenn man sieht, es gibt diesen Haider. Die Nächsten, die kamen, waren die SVP in der Schweiz. Die haben angefangen, Wildrassismus zu verbreiten.
FPÖ in Österreich?
Ja, die FPÖ natürlich. Die ist inzwischen auch aufgesprungen. Aber an die Schweizer kommen die Israels halt nicht so gut ran. Da gibt es ein traditionelles Verwirfnis, was recht lange zurückgeht. Und was wohl, naja, die Theorie ist irgendwie, dass das mit den jüdischen Geldern zu tun hat. Natürlich, die in der Schweiz auf irgendwelchen Nummern konnten lagern und die die Schweizer nicht rausrücken wollen, solange nicht Beweise auf dem Tisch liegen.
Ja, wollten die. Das ist ja dann am Ende passiert. Also zumindest gab es ja dann einen Vergleich. Aber es bildet sich halt so ein bisschen die Möglichkeit heraus, als ob es dann eine strategische Allianz gab zwischen Wilders und zumindest einigen Teilen der israelischen Rechten, die sich in Europa herausbildende populistische Strömung de facto zu hijacken und in eine Richtung zu lenken.
Dass es wenigstens nicht die Juden trifft, endlich mal.
Dass es endlich mal nicht antisemitisch wird. Also muss man schon sagen, im allgemeinen politischen Kontext in Europa nicht ganz klar war, genau. ein Fortschritt wäre, wenn es halt mal eine populistische Strömung in Europa gibt, die nicht antisemitisch ist.
Insofern ein brillanter Hack von den Israels, das muss man nicht sagen.
Aber das erklärt halt eben auch, warum das momentane Feindbild halt eben, was hochgekocht wird, überall der Islam ist.
Und das war halt der Teil der Strömung, der übrig bleibt, wenn man die... Na, irgendjemand muss es halt treffen.
Es muss halt immer gegen irgendjemand gehen, das war vollkommen klar. Und die, was wir da gerade sehen...
Na, das kann ich meinen, das ging ja nicht nur gegen den Islam. Es gibt ja auch diese Anti-Roma-Bewegung, die kommt ja auch so ein bisschen. In Frankreich hat sich das eben hauptsächlich gegen gegen Schwarze, also Araber, in den Borneus und eben gegen die Roma gerichtet. Und auch Italien hat das größte Roma-Lager Europas gehabt, in der Nähe von Rom und hat es aufgelöst. Also jedes Land hat irgendwie ihren eigenen Mechanismus, um irgendwie gerade den Volkszorn gegen irgendwelche Ausländer zu lenken, damit auch ja nicht die Regierung betroffen ist.
Ja und die Banker.
Und die Banker natürlich.
Wir müssen ja mal klar sagen, irgendwie uns in die Scheiße geritten hat, waren die Banken und von denen redet halt heute gerade mal niemand mehr. Also an der Wall Street haben sie gerade verkündet, dass irgendwie ihre Gehälter um 24 Prozent gestiegen sind. Das heißt, die haben Rekordgehälter und Rekordboni ausgezahlt und irgendwie redet davon niemand mehr. Ich finde das also eine absolute Frechheit, dass jetzt alle so tun, als wäre diese Krise irgendwie gottgegeben und eine Naturgewalt.
Die Ausländer sind schuld.
Die Ausländer sind schuld an unseren Problemen. Dabei ist doch vollkommen klar, wo irgendwie die Probleme liegen. Also die Probleme liegen in der Struktur des Finanzkapitalismus und darin, dass irgendwie niemand mehr hier davon reden mag, dass die Realwirtschaft lange nichts mehr mit der Zockerwirtschaft da draußen zu tun hat. Neulich habe ich festgestellt, dass, also wann dieser ganze Scheiß anfängt, kann man relativ klar festlegen, nämlich zu dem Zeitpunkt, als das Chicago Board of Trade, also die Börse in Chicago, die Preise und den Handel zwischen ich will meine Schweinehälften hinterher auch wirklich haben und ich will hier nur spielen, abgetrennt hat. Das heißt, die haben nichts miteinander zu tun. Also diese ganze Behauptung von wegen, ja diese optionen und so, das dient alles der Marktbildung und der Absicherung und so weiter, das ist völliger Bullshit.
Liquiditätsbeschaffung ist das offizielle Begründung.
Also es gibt da tatsächlich getrennte Märkte. Also es gibt einen Markt für, ich will meine Rohstoffe wirklich haben und ich handle damit und ich spiele hier nur.
Und der Spielmarkt ist deutlich größer?
Faktor 10. Also es ist so, dass die Zockermarktinnen mittlerweile sich in dimensionen bewegen, die mit der Realwirtschaft überhaupt nichts mehr zu tun haben und eigentlich nur noch negative Auswirkungen auf die Realwirtschaft haben können. Es gibt mittlerweile meines Erachtens keine ernsthaften, positiven Auswirkungen von den Zockermarkten auf die Realwirtschaft. Im Gegenteil, durch diese ganze asset-securitization, wo die Leute angefangen haben, ihre Straßenbahnen und whatnot mit Krediten zu belasten, damit sie an den Börsen spielen können. Und das ist ja das, worum es ihnen ging. So hat dazu geführt, dass der reale Wert aus der Realwirtschaft abgezogen wurde und in die Zockerwirtschaft ging. Und das ist das eigentliche Problem, das wir hier gerade haben und nicht irgendwie ein paar Islamisten und ein paar Minarettern in Europa.
Also es gibt ja immer wieder Verschwörungstheorien bezüglich der Amerikaner. Es ging an mit den Saudis, dass quasi der Deal war, die Saudis traden ihr Öl in Dollar und investieren die Dollars in Amerika wieder an der Wall Street. Und dafür kriegen sie halt Ammenschutz von den Amis. So quasi der Deal, den die Amis daraus kriegen, ist, dass der Dollar liquide bleibt und dass alle Leute, dass Wall Street ein hohes Trading-Niveau hat. Denn wenn man zocken will, dann will man natürlich an einem Markt zocken, wo viel los ist, damit immer garantiert man auch, dass sein Scheiß wieder los wird. Und ein ähnlicher Deal ist mit den Drogenkartellen gelaufen, heißt es. Da ist ja auch die CIA, da machen wir nochmal eine Sendung drüber. Aber da hieß es halt auch, so quasi die sitzen auch auf einem Haufen Dollars natürlich, weil der Hauptabsatzmarkt sind halt die USA und die zahlen eben nicht in Peso, sondern in Dollar. Und die Kohle legen die sich ja nicht unter die Matratze, sondern zocken damit in Amerika an den Märkten. Das heißt, die Gelder, die da investiert werden, sind auch nicht unbedingt jetzt legale Gelder, sondern die kommen doch aus der Schattenwirtschaft. Das ist tatsächlich kriminelle Elemente, die da zocken. Natürlich gibt es auch Fonds, die da zocken, aber da ist ja auch der Übergang fließend.
Ja, wie sich jetzt noch nicht so gerade bei den Besitzern von geschlossenen Immobilienfunks herausstellte, die auch nicht mehr so...
Oder Herr Madoff war ja auch lubenreiner Investor.
Ach nee, Investor.
Also der schönste Schnort an dieser Israel-Nummer war jedenfalls, wenn man da hinterher googelt, findet man raus, dass das gar nicht von denen erfunden wurde, sondern dass dasselbe auch in Israel abläuft. Denn es gibt da gerade eine Meldung, dass dem Netanyahu 98 Prozent seines Wahlkampfes von Ausländern finanziert wurde. Das sind natürlich praktisch alles Amerikaner. Und wenn man mal guckt, wer das ist, denn das wird auch tatsächlich in Israel offengelegt, das sind irgendwelche Right-wing-Spinner, die glauben, das ist jetzt Verschwörungstheorie, aber es sieht so ein bisschen so aus, als wenn es ein Instrument ist, um im Nahen Osten, wenn die Demokraten an der Macht sind, dann gibt man sein Geld irgendwie den Netanyahus und dann platzt der Friedensprozess und dann kann man irgendwie den demokratischen Präsidenten anprangern, weil er das nicht schafft, im Nahen Osten für Frieden zu sorgen. Wenn man sich anguckt, Camp David, wie das gescheitert ist, weil plötzlich die nationalkonservativen in Israel wieder vorne lagen, das war auch irgendwie ein Jahr, bevor Clintons Karriere da zu Ende war und da war klar, es gibt eine Wahl und Clinton kann nicht wieder antreten und dann können wir die Demokraten mal schlecht aussehen lassen. Das kann alles nur eine Theorie sein, aber das Timing ist auffallend.
Ja, passt ganz gut, ne?
Das passt wirklich perfekt, wenn man da ein bisschen zurückgeht. Und die Idee, dass überhaupt nicht das Volk gewählt, sondern das Ausland bestimmt über die Finanzierung des Wahlkampfes, wer da eigentlich die Stimmen kriegt, das ist schon beängstigend und da ist es schon gut, dass in Deutschland die Gesetze halbwegs stark genug sind, dass die CDU zu irgendwelchen jüdischen Vermächtnissen, Verarschungen, Schwarzen Kassen greifen muss, um da ihre Parteispenden illegal abzuwickeln.
Na also zumindest die Transparenzgesetzgebung bei Parteispenden zeigt sich in diesem Beispiel, wie eminent wichtig die für die Demokratie ist. Unbedingt. Also das ist eine Sache, wenn da gemauschelt wird, dann muss man da unmittelbar und sofort genau hingucken. Das ist denke ich mal ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Aber dass das jetzt so eine Welle ist, dass jetzt so diese islamdiskussion im Gefolge von der sarrazin-diskussion kommt.
Das ist übrigens eine Sache, auf die ich auch nochmal hinweisen wollte. Wenn wir hier sagen, die Banker sind eigentlich schuld und es wird jetzt aber gegen den Islam gewettert, das Bindeglied in der Mitte wäre ja ein Bundesbanker, der plötzlich anfängt, gegen den Islam zu wettern. Und ach, was war denn der Sarrazin, als es losging? Ja, insofern, ja, man weiß es nicht. Aber es sieht schon sehr, sieht schon sehr verdächtig aus.
Das hat auf jeden Fall irgendwie ein deutliches Gerüchtle. Naja.
Tja, wie waren wir bei Rechtsaußenpolitikern und dem Mossad?
Ja, genau, die, ja stimmt, Haider war doch doch der Lieblings-Freund.
Ja, Haider, na, da ist gerade rausgekommen, dass der BND dem eine Reise bezahlt hat, dem Haider zu Saddam Hussein. Das ist schon eine Weile her, wo man sich auch erst mal fragt, aber der Hintergrund ist wohl, dass sie gehofft haben, in der diplomatischen Begleitung von dem Haider irgendwelche Informanten unterzubringen oder so was.
Die dann aber kein Visum bekommen haben.
Also das war natürlich eine bnd-aktion, damit quasi Autofail, aber ja, also da kommen schon immer Fnords raus, nach so ein paar Jahren.
Ja, stimmt, da muss man nur noch weiter.
Man muss immer warten, bis jemand ein paar Jahre tot ist. Und dann kommt da, außer bei Barsch, weil da fehlen noch so die großen...
Stimmt, wieso ist denn bei Barsch auch noch nichts gekommen?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Also es gibt da ja Bücher, aber man weiß halt nicht, ne?
Hm, ob der vielleicht ein Tagebuch hat, oder der Stern wird er bestimmt finden. Obwohl, ich glaube, die machen nichts mehr dazu, oder?
Ich glaube, die drucken keine Tagebücher mehr.
Ich glaube, zu Barsch, da machen sie auch nichts mehr. Naja, also bei diesen Diktatoren, gibt es natürlich immer eine Menge interessante Kleinigkeiten. So eines der Dinge, die wir auch schon in der FNord News Show hatten, war ja das Putin, ist ja da auch immer ein...
Putin hat ein Schäfhaut.
Gibt es ja eine besondere Gourmetgeschichte, dass der Putin halt einen großen, schwarzen Hund hat. Und der heißt Kony. Gerüchtehalber hat er ihn so benannt nach Condoleezza Rice, also der ehemaligen amerikanischen Außenministerin und Sicherheitsberaterin.
Die ja auch schwarz ist. Also das passt schon.
Passt schon.
Schönes Gerücht.
Und irgendwann hat die Merkel dem Putin wohl mal erklärt, dass sie oder erzählt, dass sie Angst vor unten hat, weil sie als Kind mal von einem Hund gebissen wurde. Woraufhin Putin dann aber zu ihrem Treffen...
Das könnte auch in ihrer Kompromatakte gestanden haben.
Sie hat es ihm glaube ich sogar mal erzählt.
Also das war, was wir damals gehört haben. Aber ich kann es nicht vorstellen. So bescheiße kann die doch nicht sein. Ich meine die Merkel, okay, ist jetzt keine Intellektuelle, aber so blöde kann man doch nicht sein, oder? Jedenfalls seitdem, immer wenn Putin und Merkel aufeinandertreffen, hat Putin seinen Hund dabei und er ist auch so trainiert, dass er sich dann zu Merkels Füßen niederlässt und Merkel sieht noch mal richtig unbequem aus. Da kann man so ein bisschen verhalten.
Das war neulich gerade wieder der Fatz. Also die Geschichte mit der inklusive Foto, wobei sie da wohl schrieben, dass das alles gar nicht stimme, weil angeblich Hundefobiker, wenn sich ein Hund zu ihren Füßen niederlässt, dann sind sie nicht mehr so phobisch. Also das sozusagen, das war dann der, naja, anyway. Aber er hat ihr auch noch Plüschhunde geschenkt.
Also subtil ist der nicht, ne?
Na ja, also interessant ist, dass Matt Wedefatt hat dann immer seinen Hund zu Hause gelassen. Er hat auch so einen fetten Jagdhund, aber der hat den wohl so, weil die spielen ja immer...
So ein Modell Kuh, ja?
Nein, die spielen ja immer, Putin und er spielen ja immer so Good Cop, Bad Cop und so.
Ja, ja, also im Moment, wenn ihr wisst, der gute Cop.
Genau, ja. Aber dieser Hund von Cody, von Putin, die Ikone.
Das ist auch echt so ein Monster, weißt du? Das ist wie größer, ich hab mal ein Auto gehabt, das war kleiner als dieser Hund.
Na ja, das ist so großzügig.
Aber echt, ein Schaf, entschuldige.
So ein Alphamännchenhund. Interessant ist, dass Putin auch echt Spaß mit dir hat. Neulich bekam er einen Satellitenhalsband für diesen Hund geschenkt. Und zwar, Russland hat ja ein satellitennavigationsystem.
Kloner, das ist ein GPS-Klon sozusagen. Konkurrent.
Konkurrent, ja. Und die, also GPS, dieses group-position-system mit, in dem unsere Navis funktionieren und Google euer Telefon findet. Und die, also wenn er die landkartenfunktion anhat und GPS anhat, und die Russen haben halt so ein ähnliches System entwickelt, wurde das ganze Zeug ursprünglich mal, um Marschflugkörper sicher ans Ziel zu bringen. Also es war halt der, von beiden Seiten der Entwicklungsgedanke zu sagen, Marschflugkörper können nicht nur mit optischem Matching fliegen, sondern eben auch mit satellitenstützennavigation. Da haben sich die Russen natürlich ein eigenes System gebaut. Während diese Wirtanlage zusammengebrochen ist, so ein bisschen vernachlässigt worden und dementsprechend haben sie dann jetzt ein bisschen nachgerüstet, nachdem das System dann jetzt wieder funktioniert hat.
Also spannenderweise sind auch seit Jahren Satelliten da von oben und zwar genug, um Russland abzudecken, was ja doch spannend ist, weil das heißt, als sie es wieder aufgedeckt haben, aufgelegt haben das Projekt, haben sie es nicht als Militärprojekt aufgedeckt, denn sonst würde es ja über Amerika die Satelliten positionieren.
Aber der Punkt ist, dass das ungefähr das selbe ist. Die Satellitenbahnen laufen so, dass sie halt den...
Ach du meinst, Nordhalbkugel ist Nordhalbkugel?
Also so ein Band halt, was sie abdecken können. Und natürlich priorisieren sie das erstmal da, wo sie die meisten Nutzer haben und die sind normal nicht in Australien. Klar, so, ich mach das schon auf jeden Fall Sinn. In dem Fall fahren sie das System jetzt langsam wieder hoch, haben auch neue Chipsets dafür, die irgendwie mittlerweile nicht mehr Aktenkoffer groß sind. Und als Beweis dieser Inbetriebnahme haben sie dann Putin halt ein Halsband zum Verfolgen seines Hundes geschenkt.
Das war aber noch fast ein Aktending, das war relativ klobig. So wie so ein altes Mobiltelefon. Weißt du, wer dir dieser Wallstreet filmt, der gerade kam, der kam so in diese schöne Szene im Trailer, als irgendwie Gordon Gekko aus dem Knast kommt und sie geben ihm so sein Mobiltelefon wieder und es ist so ein Klonklon. Also dieses Halsband sah so aus, dass es auch ein Hund der Größe von Putins Hund braucht, um das tragen zu können. Das war nicht subtil jedenfalls. Also das ist halt so eine Trendsportart gerade, irgendwelche satellitengestützten navigationssystemen zu machen. Die EU hat auch so was angekündigt, Galileo.
Schon für eine Weile, ja.
Schon seit ewigen Zeiten und da gab es halt immer die Streitereien, weil bei EU-Projekten heißt es ja immer, die Länder, die da mitfinanzieren, die wollen auch alle quasi, dass die Steuerung bei ihnen steht. Oder die wollen zumindest an der, also erstens wollen die natürlich an dem Bau beteiligt werden, dass die Forschungsgelder und so zu ihnen fließen, genau wie bei Airbus und Hochgeschwindigkeitszügen. Das ist ja auch im Grunde Industrieförderung. Und wenn man das so als ein EU-Projekt macht, dann möchte man auch, genau wie dieser fusionsreaktor, bei dem es ja auch jahrelang Streitereien gab und jetzt soll er nach Frankreich, was auch nicht daran liegt, dass in Frankreich ein guter Standort wäre. Im Gegenteil, das ist wohl eine Erdbeben-gefährdete Zone, wo das Teil steht, also völlig bescheuert. Aber es geht eben darum, dass die Gelder für die Arbeitsplätze geschaffen werden und dass die Gelder eben in das eigene Land fließen. Das hält eben auch bei Galileo seit vielen Jahren die kommunikation, das Projekt quasi auf.
Die Chinesen haben auch ein eigenes System?
Die Chinesen haben auch ein eigenes System. Da ist aber glaube ich noch nichts von oben, oder?
Doch, vier Satelliten sind oben.
Vier sind schon oben.
Aber die wollen das doch mit Macht expandieren. Es gibt ja diese schöne Verschwörungstheorie, wieso sie bei Galileo so lange warten.
Ich finde ja immer die schönsten Theorien sind die, wo es nicht heißt, da die sind halt blöde, sondern wo man so einen Sinn dahinter erkennt.
Inkompetenz als strategisches.
Genau, strategische Inkompetenz. Das ist ja auch in Firmen so. Wenn du nicht möchtest, dass die Leute dir ständig Aufgaben übergeben, an denen du dich dann abarbeitest, dann bist du halt strategisch inkompetent und dann kriegst du nur noch leichte Jobs. Und so ist das mit Galileo auch, wenn man genau hinguckt. Denn was jetzt passiert, ist, dass sie das lange genug hinaus zögern, dass alle anderen ihr System schon oben haben und dass wir kein Galileo mehr bauen müssen. Und wir haben quasi nichts verloren, außer dass wir jahrelang verhandelt haben dabei. Und der eigentliche Hintergrund bei Galileo war ja, dass wir gerne GPS-Konkurrenten haben wollen, weil damals gab es dann das Modemodul der Amis. Ja, und die Verhandlung mit den Amerikanern lief auch relativ bescheuert. Da gab es dann nämlich die Übereinkunft, dass sie auf derselben Frequenz senden, damit wir uns nicht gegenseitig jammen können. Also es ist sich ewig lang alles hingezogen. Ich glaube inzwischen, dass es Absicht war, dass sie ewig lange verhandeln. Denn das Ergebnis ist jetzt, dass wir Alternativsysteme kriegen, ohne selber eins bauen zu müssen.
Also alle haben geglaubt, wir bauen eins, außer wir selber.
Genau, alle außer uns selber waren überzeugt, dass sie schnell fertig werden müssen, bevor die Europäer ihr System oben haben. Und am Ende bauen wir dann gar keins und haben auch nichts verloren dabei.
Wir nehmen halt das Chinesische, Russische, Indische und Amerikanische, weil alle zusammen werden sie schon nicht aufeinander auf uns einkloppen, sondern wir machen einfach differenzial Ausgleich und Erkennnahmen, wenn eines ausgefallen ist.
Und haben also im Grunde ein genialer Plan. Man weiß halt nicht, ob sie das absichtlich machen oder nicht. Aber ich möchte es gern glauben, weil ich finde, ich finde es mal eine schöne Vorstellung, dass sie eigentlich gar nicht so blöde sind. Das hoffe ich ja immer insgeheim.
Hoffst du?
Ich hoffe, dass ja.
Also dieses Verteilen im Industriemaßstab können die Amerikaner natürlich auch sehr gut. Also gerade kam die Meldung raus, dass Clinton hatte wohl über Monate hinweg seinen Nuklear-Launch-Codes, also die Codes zur Autorisierung von Atomschlägen, verbummelt.
Also nicht er selbst. Er wusste gar nicht, dass sie verbunden sind. Aber der Lacher war, Sie haben halt, also dieser Artikel erzählt halt, dass Sie immer, irgendjemand, Sie wollten die Codes irgendwann austauschen. Dabei ist es dann aufgeflogen. Bei der Gelegenheit wollten Sie halt die Alten einsammeln. Und es gab halt so Tonus-mäßige Überprüfungen, so ob sie die Codes noch haben. Und da hat der zuständige Fuzzi immer gesagt, ja, die hat ja Präsident und der ist gerade in einem wichtigen Meeting und ich kann nicht stören. Und dann haben sie immer gesagt, naja gut, okay, dann lassen wir mal irgendwie beiseite. Und aber als dann am Ende die Codes ausgetauscht werden sollten, da ging es halt nicht mehr. Da mussten sie die alten Codes rausrücken und da hat dann der zuständige Typ zugeben müssen, dass sie seit Monaten nicht wissen, wo diese Codes eigentlich sind. Das ist schon ziemlich hart eigentlich.
Diese Nuklear-Launch-Codes, die man ja nun denken sollte, sind nun das beste gehütete Ding auf diesem Planeten. Da kam ja vor einer...
Völlig unratbar.
Vor längerer Zeit raus, dass die so zu früheren Zeiten, als es noch Minutemen-Raketen waren, waren die aus Sicherheitsgründen auf 10-mal die Null oder so gesetzt. 8-mal die Null.
Und zwar alle. Bei allen Minutemen-Raketen war das so bis 1976.
Und zwar, weil sie das Militär der Politik nicht zutraut, im Ernstfall die Kurz rauszurücken. Super. Also sie wollten ihre Einsatzautonomität bewahrben. Also interessant ist ja, wie diese Lounge-Codes funktionieren. Und zwar ist es so, dass die im Idealfall, also bei den Systemen, die so funktionieren, wie es im Buch steht, beeinflussen diese Codes tatsächlich die Zündsequenz der Sprengstoffumantelung um den Plutoniumkern. Also bei der Atomwaffe hat man innen drin so eine hohle Plutoniumkugel und die wird durch ringsrum angebrachte Sprengstofflinsen komprimiert. Das heißt also, der Sprengstoff wird ringsrum synchron gezündet und komprimiert dieses Plutonium-Ding zusammen, sodass es in der Mitte kritische Masse kriegt. Und einer der Sicherheitsmechanismen, der publiziert wurde dazu, ist, dass sie diese Kugel in der Mitte nicht rund machen, sondern so mehr so kartoffelförmig. Und da die Zündsequenz, um präzise zu zünden, ja relativ einfach ist, wenn man eine Kugel hat, dann zündet man halt alle.
Alle gleichzeitig?
Ja, mindestens alle gleichzeitig.
Mit demselben Druck?
Nicht ganz, stimmt nicht ganz, aber fast. Also jedenfalls kann man es relativ einfach ausrechnen. Aber wenn du nicht weißt, wie die Kartoffelförmigkeit von diesem Objekt in der Mitte drin ist, und da gibt es noch 1000 Tricks mit irgendwie unterschiedlichen Sprengstoffen und solchen Geschichten, dann kannst du nicht wissen, wie die Timings von den Zündern sein müssen, mit denen nur diese Atomaffizienz ist. Das heißt also, die Idee hinter diesen Control-Codes ist, selbst wenn der Russe unsere Bombe findet, kann er sie nicht zünden. Oder böse Terroristen ist jetzt gerade der...
Ich meine ja die Terroristen.
Böse Terroristen, genau. Kann er damit nichts anfangen, sondern müsste halt das Plutonium daraus kratzen, neue Gießen und Plutonium-Metallurgie ist nun auch nichts für Leute mit schwachen Herzen. Also Plutonium ist eine super eklig Substanz, das hatten wir schon mal. Na ja, wo wir gerade bei Atomraketen waren. Atomraketen haben natürlich immer eine Menge an Technologie inspiriert, um sie sichtbar zu machen, abzuwerden oder sonst irgendwie zu kontrollieren.
Zu erkennen.
Erkennen, genau. Und eines der beeindruckendsten Technologiebeispiele aus dieser Richtung sind ja diese über Horizont-Radars. Das heißt also große Radaranlagen, die gebaut wurden, um Raketen zu erkennen, die man eigentlich noch nicht sehen kann. Also die jenseits der Erdkrümmung auf einen zugeflogen kommen. Dazu benutzt man reflexionen an der Ionosphäre. Das heißt also, man wählt Frequenzen, die im Kurzwellenbereich relativ niedrig sind, die an der Ionosphäre gebounced werden, um dann wiederum reflexionen darin zu erkennen. Und also die typische Frequenz ist sowas wie 7 bis 19 MHz, die die Russen benutzt haben. Und eines dieser Geräte war in der Nähe von Tschernobyl. Das war, wie heißt das Ding, Duga 3? Duga 3.
Also in der Nähe ist es untertrieben. Das steht irgendwie zwei Kilometer neben Tschernobyl.
So dicht?
Richtig dicht, ja.
Okay.
Also das ist, wenn du bei Google Maps nahe genug ranzoomst, dass du Tschernobyl siehst, hast du das Teil quasi mit auf der Map. Das ist echt nah dran. Oder vielleicht sind es auch 10 Kilometer. Aber es ist halt echt, du kannst...
Also ich glaube, es wird schon ein bisschen weiter sein, weil die Energie, die da rauskommt, wenn du 10 mio. als HLF hast, da willst du keinen AKW daneben haben.
Das ist doch geschildet. Außerdem ist das Russen-Nächte-Lung, was kann da schon passieren? Das war doch sicher.
Ja, also ich denke, es ist eher so 30, 50 Kilometer weg, aber jedenfalls in der Nähe.
Jedenfalls der Punkt war, dass so ein Teil genug Energie zieht, dass man eigentlich auch mal ein Atomkraftwerk daneben bauen könnte. Und das ist wohl auch eine der Theorien. Also es gab ja nach dem Tschernobyl-Hochgehen, gab es ja die ersten tollen Theorien, dass sie da irgendeinen Keller haben, in dem sie ein UFO gefangen haben, weil es irgendwie hieß, naja, okay, der betreibt Kiev, der Reaktor. Ja, aber an sich braucht man in der Gegend nicht so viel Saft. Ja, aber da haben sie halt übersehen, dass dieses Radar daneben steht und das zieht eben unglaublich, unglaubliche Energiemengen, diesen Sender zu betreiben. Denn da reflektiert zwar was, aber eben nicht alles, ja. Und damit das überhaupt so weit kommt, muss man da, was meinst du, 10 Megawatt reinhauen?
Die 10 Mega ist die HF-Leistung. Das heißt also, das, was du da an Strom rein tust, ist nochmal ein Vielfaches davon. Und so im Vergleich ist es zum Beispiel so ein Telefon. Ein Mobiltelefon hat maximal 2 Watt Sendeleistung und 10 Megawatt sind halt irgendwie 10 millionen Watt, die denn da rausgebrezelt kommen. Das heißt, das ist so viel Energie wie die Sendeleistung von 5 millionen Mobiltelefonen, um es sich mal irgendwie vorzustellen. Also wenn alle Leute in Berlin alle ihre Telefone gleichzeitig anmachen und senden, dann kommt da so ein ungefähr so ähnlicher Energielevel raus, nur halt eben als einen Puls. Und dieses Überhorizontradar war im Westen auch bekannt unter Funkamateuren als Woodpecker, weil das Signal...
Der hat immer so...
Was sie da gesagt haben, ist so, das faded so ein bisschen so... Vielleicht spielen wir das ja noch mal ein, gucken wir mal, ob wir noch ein Signal finden, dann können wir es ja noch mal reinschneiden.
Der hat halt immer die armen Funkamateure genervt.
Nein, nicht nur die Funkamateure, sondern auch radioempfänger. Kurzweilend radio war halt durchaus schon betroffen davon. Also da gibt es halt auch eine Menge Mitschnitte so von Interferenzen mit normalen radiosendern.
Aber es ist halt national Security. Das ist schon irgendwie einsehbar, dass sie da mal auf die radios geschissen haben.
Ja, die Russlander haben sowieso darauf geschissen. Interessant ist, dass in der Sowjetterlande hatten sie halt mehrere von den Dingern, von diesen Woodbaker-Radars, die strategisch halt alle Anflugruten von Atomaketen Richtung Sowjetterland abdecken sollten. Und da gab es diese Geschichte, als Tschernobyl ausfiel.
Das war den Amis nicht unbekannt, dass da die...
Dass plötzlich der Radar aus war.
Dass auch der Radar aus war und dass das die die Abschreckung der Russen reduziert. Und die Amis haben sich Sorgen gemacht, dass die Russen nervös werden könnten.
Aber war es denn nicht so, dass die, dass in Tschernobyl haben sie doch auch nach der Katastrophe zwei von den vier Blöcken weiter betrieben? War es denn nicht so, dass sie einen von den Blöcken präzise für diesen Radar weiter betrieben haben?
Das kannst du ja als Ami nicht sehen.
Kannst du hören.
Naja, warte mal, also ich... Das können wir mal recherchieren, aber ich glaube, dass das Ding aus war. Also ich habe jedenfalls in der US-Presse gelesen, irgendwann, dass die Amis sich Sorgen gemacht haben, dass die Russen denken könnten, wenn die Amis... Also die Russen wussten, dass die Amis wissen, dass sie da den überhorizonten Radar haben und dass der betroffen sein könnte von Tschernobyl. Und die Amis haben sich Russen, haben sich Sorgen gemacht, dass die Russen wissen, dass sie da jetzt ein Einschussloch haben, wo sie quasi eine Rakete reinfliegen könnten, ohne dass die Russen das sehen.
Aus der Richtung Westeuropa, wo die Mittelstreckenraketen sind, ja?
Also auch durchaus naheliegend und die sind ja auch nahe genug dran, dass das auch ein Problem wäre, da zeitnah zu reagieren, wenn man das nicht rechtzeitig mitkriegt. Also die Amis haben sich Sorgen gemacht, dass die Russen halt so nervös werden, dass da jemand auf den Knopf drückt und haben tatsächlich das Angebot unterbreitet, den Russen, ob sie nicht temporär als Leihstellung einen von den US über Horizontradars haben wollen, um quasi das Loch zu schließen, damit wieder alle schön abgeschreckt sind und alles gut bleibt so. Und die Russen haben natürlich abgelehnt. Das hätte ja auch irgendwie eine weitere Bombe sein können. Oder nach dieser Pipeline-Sache, die wir letztes Mal erwähnt haben, die fette pipeline-explosion, da wollten sie keine US-Dentalogie mehr haben wieder. Also, aber da sieht man, wie ernst die Lage ist, wenn die Amis so im Angebot greifen.
Das ist ja nun durchaus Rocket-Technologie, die da drin steckt.
Das ist national Security. Das hätte man auch reverse-ingenieren können und daraus finden können, wie man an einem Amiradar vorbeikommt.
Tja, naja.
Also gut, da waren alle sehr nervös. Und nicht nur, weil dieses Kraftwerk da geschmolzen ist, sondern auch aus national Security Gründen.
Also dieses Radar da, beziehungsweise bei Charmobile, hat es dann auch in die Pop-Kultur geschafft. Und zwar in dem Spiel Stalker.
Also berühmt geworden ist das, weil auf Englisch, Russia, so Bilder waren von einem kaputten... Also es ging damit los, es gab irgendwie diese Frau, die mit ihrem Motorrad durch die Gegend gefahren ist und Fotos gemacht hat und das war ja eine internetsensation vor vielen Jahren, in den 90ern irgendwann. Und es gab danach Bilder von einem Typ, also auf den Bildern von der Frau konnte man dieses Radar sehen und dann gab es halt einen Freikletterer, der ist dahin gefahren, in die radioaktive Zone, ist zu diesem fetten Monsterradar gefahren und hat nicht nur Fotos gemacht, sondern ist da hochgeklettert. Und das Teil, ich weiß nicht, wie hoch das ist, aber es sind hunderte von Metern, das ist scheiße groß. Und es ist ein Wunder, also das muss auch echt finster befestigt sein, damit es allein, was es dem Wind für eine Angriffsfläche geboten haben muss, dass das nicht einfach umkippt. Und es ist natürlich auf so einer Art Hügel steht das da, weil man will ja von da aus gute Sicht haben.
Jedes bisschen Reichweite, was man kriegen kann.
Ja, also und es gibt halt super geile Bilder von diesem Typ, wie er auf dieses Radar hochklettert und Fotos macht, wo man einfach mal sieht, was das für ein Monster ist. Und da ist ziemlich sicher, dass das Ding nicht mehr in Betrieb war, als dieser Typ da hochgeklettert ist, weil sonst wäre der einfach mal gegrillt worden. Und seitdem ist das halt in der Popkultur dieses Radar und hat es eben bis in diese Stalker-Spiele geschafft.
Genau, in Stalker hat es dann den Titel, dass es ein Mind-Control-System ist, mit dem schönen Titel Brain-Scorcher, also Hirn-Schmelzer.
Wir haben uns ja für nächstes Mal vorgenommen, ein bisschen auf russische Mind-Control-Sachen und ähnliche Spielreihen einzugehen. Das sparen wir uns dieses Mal.
Das sparen wir uns dieses Mal, aber...
Aber als Teil der Popkultur ist es halt.
Ja, also gerade Games sind ja nun irgendwie Teil der Popkultur. Hast du Stalker denn gespielt?
Nee, Stalker habe ich gerade nicht gespielt. Wollte ich eigentlich immer mal, besonders weil ich eben auch gehört habe, dass es gut modbar ist. Das ist eigentlich immer ein Anziehungspunkt für Spiele. Aber naja, diese Spieleindustrie geht mir auch zu sehens...
Ja, irgendwie bist du jedes Mal unglücklich, wenn du so Spiele kaufst, ne?
Ja, also es gibt da mehrere Gründe. Also ursprünglich war es ja so, man hat die Spiele halt, wenn man sie gekauft hat, hat man so eine Floppy gekriegt, ganz lange her. Und da haben die dann irgendwelche Spezial-Floppys gemacht, wo dann so ein so mit einer Nadelnloch eingestochen war, damit der Sektor kaputt war. Und man konnte das halt zwar kopieren, aber man konnte das nicht so kopieren, dass auf der Zielfloppy auch genau dieser Sektor kaputt war. Und dann gab es halt Kopiertools, die dann eben andere Fehler gemacht haben und aber der Software vorgegaukelt haben, dass da wieder dieser Fehler ist und das hat nie lang gedauert, bis die Piraten das kopiert haben.
Genau, aber ich meine, so ist doch irgendwie, haben doch die allermeisten Leute, die heute in der Securityindustrie unterwegs sind, irgendwie ihr erstes Reverse-Engineering gelernt, mit Spiele-Cracken.
Richtig, das ist so was wie der Grundwehrdienst bei Computer-Security-Leuten. Ich habe da auch mal ein lustiges Gespräch belaut, ich sage jetzt nicht zwischen wem auf dem Kongress, aber so ein paar Erzhacker, die auf dem Kongress festgestellt haben, dass sie in derselben Gruppe gehackt haben, aber halt unter irgendwelchen Pseudonymen von denen. Also ja, so ist das in der Branche.
Also die Spieleindustrie sorgt sozusagen für den Hacker-Dachwuchs.
Sorgt für den Hacker-Dachwuchs, und das ist ja auch gut so.
Aber ich meine, am Ende stellt sich doch schon die Frage, jedes Mal wenn du so ein Spiel gekauft hast, warst du echt angepisst, kann ich mir erinnern.
Ja, das ist auch wirklich jedes fucking Mal. Naja, also es ging halt immer mit diesen scheißen Medien. Und dann bei den floppy Disketten ist das ja noch so, dass die nach zwei Jahren einfach von sich aus den Geist aufgeben und dass der Spielehersteller natürlich dann auch irgendwie keinen Bock mehr hat, jeder neue Floppies zuzuschicken. Und das ist ja auch ein Bürokratieakt, den man nicht haben will. Und also man wird im Grunde ist man schon immer dafür bestraft worden, wenn man zu den ehrlichen Kunden gehört und man ist belohnt worden, wenn man Pirat war. Aber ich bin jetzt im Alter, da denke ich über die Rente nach und da möchte ich auch meine Spiele gern legal kaufen und habe das also mehrfach gemacht und das geht auch immer noch nach hinten los. Also es ist so, erstens haben die Preisschwankungen zwischen den Ländern dramatische Ausmaße angenommen inzwischen.
Machen die da auch so ein Ding, dass du keine britischen Spiele nach Deutschland importieren darfst oder so, wie die Pharma-Lobby da?
Das hätten sie gerne. Das ist eine der Gründe, hinter Akte meines Erachtens nach. Da reden sie nämlich immer davon, dass Güter illegal importiert werden, graue Importe. Sie sagen natürlich immer Pharma, aber ich glaube, sie meinen eigentlich so was wie Computerspiele. Also das Pfund ist gerade so schwach, das britische Pfund, dass es sich lohnt, Computerspiele in England zu kaufen. Ich habe neulich mal geguckt, also das Spiel, an dem ich aktuell Interesse hatte, war Fallout New Vegas. Das ist so ein Rollenspiel, postapokalyptisch, deswegen passt das auch ganz gut gerade in unser Themengebiet hier. Und wenn man das hier im Laden kauft, kostet das 50 Euro.
Spannender Geld.
Genau, wenn man das bei Amazon UK kauft, sind das 25 Pfund und das sind ungerechnet irgendwie 28 Euro.
Was? Wo ist das Pfund gerade?
Ja, das Pfund ist richtig am Boden. Weil das England ist, ist es auch EU-Binnenkram.
Also kein Zoll-Scheiß?
Man hat auch keinen Zoll-Scheiß am Bein. Das heißt, wenn ich gerade Spiele kaufe, kaufe ich die eigentlich alle in England. Und das Problem ist aber, dass diese Spielehersteller sich, das ist nicht nur in England so, das ist genauso, wenn du es hier kaufst. Also hier hast du noch zusätzlich das Problem, dass du irgendeine beschissen eingedeutschte version kriegst. Ja, das ist eine Sache, die ich abgrundtief verachte. Wenn sich die Mundbewegung, das ist schon, also wir haben jetzt seit 20 Jahren, ist das so, erst haben sie überhaupt keine Mundbewegung gehabt in den Spielen, die Figuren und dann haben sie Mundbewegung gekriegt und sie passten nicht zu den Stimmen und inzwischen passen sie zu den Stimmen, aber nicht, wenn du die Scheiße in Deutschland kriegst. So deswegen, das kommt für mich überhaupt nicht in Frage, irgendwie eine deutsche version zu holen, das geht gar nicht. Und das ist früher auch noch echt ein Problem gewesen, die die englische version zu kriegen, weil es in Deutschland immer diese Jugendschutzscheiße gibt. Das heißt, die Hersteller brauchen länger für die Eindeutschung, nicht nur wegen der Übersetzung, sondern weil sie dann irgendwie grünes Kunstblut einbauen und aus den Feinden Androiden bauen, damit man sie erschießen darf, ohne den Jugendschutz zu verletzen und so ein Dreck. Und seit es gibt also eine eigene Szene, die sich bemüht, irgendwelche Nach-Patches, ja Blatt-Patches heißt das dann, um die violins wiederherzustellen in den Spielen, dass es schön blutig spritzt, wenn man jemanden totschießt.
Ich muss ja zugeben, ich bevorzuge das ja, wenn meine Computerspiele nicht so schleimig sind. Also weniger Körperflüssigkeit, finde ich ja ganz gut, aber meistens kann man das ja auch normal ausschalten.
Ja, ja, genau. Aber es ist halt so, dass das den Deutschen geradezu antrainiert wird, dass sie das haben wollen.
Dadurch, dass es verboten ist.
Dadurch, dass es verboten ist. Natürlich. Ja, natürlich. Und ich kaufe halt die Spiele gleich in England und das ist eigentlich auch in Ordnung, aber da passieren dann eben so Sachen wie, dass das Spiel einfach mal eine Woche später bei mir tatsächlich da ist. Als es in der Piratenszene verfügbar ist.
Du hättest schon torrenten können.
Ich hätte es nicht nur torrenten können, ich hätte es durchspielen können, bevor ich es tatsächlich in der Hand habe. Und das ärgert mich halt richtig. Und es liegt gar nicht mal in England, sondern es ist einfach so, dass die die Hersteller dann auch zu wenig ausliefern oder dann gibt es irgendwie eine Special edition. Und inzwischen ist es so, dass ein Teil der Finanzierung so läuft, dass sie Preorders machen. Also wenn du ein Spiel kaufst, bevor es verfügbar ist, also das läuft auch schon seit vielen Jahren. Es gab neulich so ein super schönes Bild von einem Typ, der 1995 Nukem gekauft hat. Und er hat halt den Preorder-Bong von irgendwie echt, der ist schon so vergilbt, du kannst kaum noch lesen, was er da bezahlt hat. Und ja, also das ist immer noch so. Und deswegen wollen sie natürlich die Leute bestrafen, die nicht Preorder machen und die dann die reguläre edition kaufen. Inzwischen ist es aber wenigstens so, dass die Hersteller festgestellt haben, dass sie gegenüber den Piraten so verloren haben, mit dem zu spät liefern, dass es immerhin der Preis dann schnell weniger wird. Das muss man echt sagen, das hat sich geändert. Heutzutage ist es so...
Also ein paar Wochen warten, dann macht die Games billiger.
Genau, nach ein paar Wochen ist es normalerweise deutlich billiger. Und inzwischen also eine der verbreitetsten Plattformen, um Spiele digital runterzuladen, ist eben Steam. Und die haben so eine Art Länderschutz, aber der ist sehr wenig ausgeprägt. Das heißt, es gibt so Läden im Internet, die verkaufen dir dann ein Steam-Key und kaufen den aber in Singapur ein oder irgendwie so was. Und da ist halt die Wirtschaft nicht so ausgeprägt wie hier. Deswegen sind die Preise da günstiger. Das heißt, es gibt Mittel und Wege, so eine Art Grauimport zu machen, aber über halt den Key hast du doch eine gültige Lizenz und die ist gültig genug, dass du dir das dann halt vom Original-Servoir runterladen könntest, als hättest du es hier gekauft. Also es gibt abseitig der Piracy, gibt es auch andere Möglichkeiten, wie man die Hersteller ärgern kann. Aber das alles ärgert die alle noch bei weitem nicht so viel wie der Verleih von Software. Oder wenn du das Spiel gebraucht weiter verkaufst. Also das ist das, was die eigentlich ärgert. Dass sie gegen die Piraten nichts tun können, haben sie schon gelernt. Sie machen das nur noch pro forma. Also sie machen das zwar immer noch, aber es gibt halt sofort ein Patchespiel. Das ist keine Rolle. Aber was sie halt richtig ärgert, ist dieses Legale, du gehst in die Videothek, kaufst sie das Spiel, kopierst es dann. Das ist ja an sich legal. Das Cracken des Kopierschutzes ist halt nicht legal in Deutschland. Deswegen gibt es noch die AM.
Ich meine, wieso kaufen Leute nicht einfach ein Game, spielen es durch ihn, verkaufen es weiter?
Na, erstens tun sie das, weil die Preise inzwischen echt schnell runtergehen. Das ist einer der Gründe, warum die Preise schnell runtergehen, ist, weil sich das einfach nicht mehr lohnt. Du kriegst da irgendwie noch fünf Euro für und dann kannst du auch bald.
Verstehe. Also ich meine, die andere Sache ist... Bei so Nintendo Games zum Beispiel kann ich mich deutlich erinnern.
Bei Konsolen ist es anders, aber bei PC-Spielen ist es so, dass sie auf der einen Seite fast alle Spiele versuchen, inzwischen nicht an irgendeinen blöden Service zu binden. Du musst du dann aktivieren und an deinen Account binden. Und damit kannst du es auch nicht weiter verkaufen, weil das ist halt schon an deinen Account gebunden. Das heißt, der kannst du dann nicht mehr aktivieren.
Ach, das ist ja interessant.
Und die alternative Strategie sind diese downloadable Content-Sachen. Das heißt, du kaufst das Spiel, aber du kriegst halt nur 80 Prozent von dem Content. Und irgendwelche Bonus-Content-Sachen, die gibt es dann auch beim Spiele-Start schon kostenlos zum Runterladen, aber erst, wenn du es aktiviert hast.
Das heißt, du musst dann dein Aktivierungscode eingeben und dann ist der verbrannt und dann kannst du...
Dann ist der verbrannt, genau. Das heißt, der nächste, dem du das Spiel verkaufst, der kann, hat dann diesen Bonus-Content nicht und der kauft sich das dann lieber für drei Euro mehr offiziell im Laden, als die abzukaufen. Also das sind aktuell die Strategien, wie die Spielebranche versucht, sich da den Markt zu retten. Aber diese DLC-Scheiße ist ansonsten voll nach hinten losgegangen. Also EA...
Also DLC ist downloadable Content.
Downloadable Content, genau. Die Idee ist also, dass du quasi extra Levels speziell herunterladen kannst. Der einzige, bei dem es funktioniert, ist Steam. Denn da ist der kostenlos. Genau, da ist es einfach mal kostenlos. Das heißt, Valve-Software ist eine Loyalty-Geschichte. Und es funktioniert auch richtig doll gut, denn die verkaufen immer noch ein Spiel. Team Fortress 2, das ist von 2006 oder so. Also das ist nach heutigen Standards ein steinaltes Spiel. Und das verkaufen die immer noch. Und sie machen auch immer noch richtig Umsatz damit, weil es einfach immer wieder neuen Content gibt und es immer wieder neue Leute anzieht.
Neue Level und so?
Ja, es gibt neue Levels, es gibt irgendwie neue Items, alles mögliche neue.
Verstehe, okay.
Das gibt es aber nur für PC, nicht für die Konsolen. Die sind geschmiert. Bei Konsolen gibt es auch ein Down-Double-Content-Modell. Aber da musst du dann durch die DRM-Scheiße von Sony und Microsoft durch. Und das kostet die Hersteller Geld. Das ist sogar so schlimm, dass Valve neulich so ein PR-Gag gab. Da gab es irgendwie neues Down-Double-Content für Left 4 Dead 2. Und das haben sie auf dem PC, haben sie das Spiel, inklusive des neuen Contents, für weniger verkauft, als nur der neue Content auf der Konsole gekostet hat. Also die Konsolenleute werden noch viel übler abgezogen, als die PC-Zocker. Also wenn du ein neues Spiel anguckst, wie Fallout, dann kostet es in England wie gesagt 25 Pfund für die pc-version oder 35 Pfund, dasselbe Spiel, für eine Konsole. Also es ist mir total unbegreiflich, warum irgendjemand Konsolenspiele kauft, weil da wirst du einfach nur über den Tisch gezogen. Aber das ist halt, weiß nicht, kindertauglich oder so.
Na gut, aber dann musst du dich halt auch nicht mit diesem ganzen, brauchst du noch diese Turbo-Grafikkarte neu zum Spiel.
Ja, aber das ist so wie Apple, weißt du. Du hast die ganze Zeit, halten sie dir sofort die Nase, du wirst gerade abgezockt. Und du merkst es, wenn du in App Store gehst, dann steht überall der Preis dran. Das ist so eine Sache, die ich überhaupt nicht abkann. So auch, wenn ich irgendwie beim öffentlichen Nahverkehr für jede scheiß Fahrt irgendwie ein Ticket kaufen muss, dann habe ich die ganze Zeit dieses Gefühl vor Augen, ich zahle hier gerade. Das ist die ganze Zeit so eine negative Sache und die wird jedes Mal reinforced, wo ich wieder zahlen muss. Und das Gegenmodell, dass du einfach einmal blutest und danach ist aber der Rest wenigstens frei, das funktioniert schon bei Disneyland besser als auf dem Oktoberfest. Ich zahle lieber einmal dick am Anfang und da habe ich dann wenigstens den Rest des Tages Lust und Spaß.
Das ist sozusagen das Bankard-100-Modell.
Genau, das kostet ja auch nochmal 5 Euro und du bist die ganze Zeit an deinem Portemonnaie und denkst, oh, könnte ich mir das jetzt auch sparen? Diese Gedankengänge willst du doch gar nicht haben, an einem Tag, wo es geht hier darum, Spaß zu haben mit den ganzen Spielen, Entertainment-Zeug. Und das machen sie halt völlig kaputt mit diesem Nickel- und Dime-Scheiß. Hier nochmal 5 Euro und da kriegst du eine neue Rüstung für. Das ist doch alles Scheiße.
Na gut, ich meine, Apple hat natürlich im App Store auch kostenlose Sachen, aber das ist halt auch so ein Ding, wo, also ich bin ja bekennender Apple-User und muss aber sagen, dass so langsam ist Apple wirklich auf dem Weg nach Mordor. Also was sie jetzt planen mit 10.7, dass sie den App Store halt auch als software-distributionsplattform ins normale Mac OS einbauen, was bisher ja nur primär für iPhones und iPads war.
Super.
Hat natürlich den Vorteil für die Software-Entwickler, dass sie halt einen relativ einfachen Weg haben, Software auf die Geräte zu kriegen. Auf der anderen Seite ist es aber so, dass dann halt der ganze Apple-DM drin ist. Also du hast dann halt den ganzen Licensing, die Bindung aufs Gerät, hast du die Software.
Du hast einmal Apple-Zensur drin. Das ist Indecent-Content, den wollen wir nicht.
Apple-Zensur drin, das ist halt schon ein echter Punkt. Und nicht nur Indecent-Content, sondern Apple unterdrückt offensichtlich ja auch Software, die ihren eigenen Produkten Konkurrenz macht. Das ist ein Mailprogramm, sowas haben wir schon. Auf dem iPad zum Beispiel gibt es ja delicious Library, was halt so ein Bookstore-Bookverwaltungsprogramm ist. Und die prügeln sich bis heute mit Apple rum, weil Apple ja iBooks hat, also ihr eigenes System. Weil sie andere Bücher, Sachen wie zum Beispiel Texte haben sie zugelassen, weil sie die offenbar nicht nahe genug dranfanden oder so. Aber die Art und Weise, wie die da wirklich ausüben, dass sich das jetzt auch noch auf die Mainstream-Plattform, also auf die Computer ausbreiten soll, ist dann halt schon irgendwie eine ziemliche Faschennummer.
Aber so ist es die ganze Zeit bei Apple. Es ist nur so, dass sie dir bisher so einen Spalt gelassen haben, über den du dich selber davon überzeugen kannst, dass es vielleicht, na ja, wenigstens auf meinem Laptop habe ich noch Ruhe. Und den machen sie jetzt halt auch noch zu.
Naja, bloß das ist halt der kritische Spalt. Das ist halt eben die, also...
Die wollen da nicht mal mehr Flash ausliefern fürs, äh, wie heißt das Ding, MacBook Air?
Ja gut, meine Flash-Hooker ist...
Nein, aber ich meine, das ist doch auch im Grunde eine Frechheit. Was bilden die sich eigentlich ein?
Naja, Gott, ich meine...
Entschuldige mal.
Naja, vielleicht das Ende von Flash ist doch eine gute Sache.
Na und? Das ist nicht Apples Entscheidung.
Naja, das kannst du ja immer noch installieren. Na Frechheit. Also ich meine, dass sie Flash nicht...
Nein, aber ich meine...
Das Broken Adobe-Software nicht ausliefern, ist eigentlich ein Fortschritt. Da tut sich der Menschheit tatsächlich immer auch gefallen, dass sie die Leute dazu zwingen, auf Artikel 15 Migräne und von dieser Broken Flash-Kacke runterzukommen.
Ja, genau.
Also das würde ich gerne tatsächlich noch verteidigen.
Also den Aspekt, dass irgendwie Flash scheiße ist und Adobe getreten gehört, den verteidige ich natürlich auch. Aber ich finde nicht, dass das an Apple liegt. Weißt du, Microsoft hat auch seit zehn Jahren irgendwie die Wahl, Flash nicht auszuliefern. Und machen das nicht. Und wenn wir vor Microsoft die Flash nicht ausliefern, dann würden die Leute doch alle irgendwie mit Flaschen werfen. Aber bei Apple kommen dann plötzlich die Opäologen und sagen, ja, aber jetzt haben wir doch HTL5. Und eigentlich ist der Steve Jobs ist doch ein Menschenfreund und tut das doch so unseren Besten.
Der Unterschied ist doch irgendwie, dass Apple sagt, lass uns mal HTL5 nehmen, was ein Standard ist. Wenn Microsoft sagt, lass uns mal Silverlight nehmen, was irgendwie so eine Microsoft-only-Nischen-Rankruppen-Angelegenheit ist.
Hey, Silverlight kannst du auch für Apple runterladen.
Ja, schön, wer würde das tun?
Na wer hat einer unserer Kumpels das neulich gemacht, weil er eine Fußball-Übertragung sehen wollte?
Ja, also gut, aber jedenfalls der wichtige Punkt ist halt, dass ich hoffe, dass die eu-kommission nochmal dazwischenklopft, weil Apple mittlerweile Dinge tut, die Microsoft, da würde Microsoft zurecht für gekreuzigt werden.
Apple ist jetzt, wie war das, wen haben die alles überholt? Die machen einen derartigen, unglaublichen Gewinn gerade.
Microsoft haben sie auch überholt.
Microsoft hat die Zahlen noch nicht bekanntgegeben, las ich neulich an, ansonsten, deswegen kann man noch nicht sagen, ob sie die auch überholt haben, aber so.
Letztes Quartal hatten sie schon.
Krasse, krasse Scheiße.
Also deren Margen sind halt echt utopisch und die, also deren Market-Share wächst natürlich auch immer weiter, aber.
Also das ist allein für mich ein Grund, deren Sachen nicht zu kaufen. Dieses Gefühl, ich werde hier gerade abgezockt, so solche Leuten gebe ich kein Geld, selbst wenn ich das wirklich dringend haben will.
Also das Gefühl, abgezockt zu werden, habe ich regelmäßig, wenn ich irgendwie eine Kopie von Microsoft Office kaufen soll, dann fühle ich mich so richtig abgezockt.
Ist beim PC dabei?
Naja, so ein richtiges Office nicht.
Klar kann man dazu klicken, natürlich. Da ist dann vielleicht irgendwie nicht visio dabei, aber wer will visio haben?
Die man braucht sind dann halt nicht dabei.
visio?
Ich meine, ich benutze OmniGraph für so etwas, nicht visio.
Ist ja egal. Ich will jetzt hier nicht Office verteidigen. Bring mich hier mal nicht in Verlegenheit.
Jetzt habe ich eine Ecke. Jetzt muss er Office verteidigen. Ich muss zugeben, dass das Apple-Fanboy-Tum natürlich an einigen Stellen schon quasi religiöse Züge hat, was sicherlich damit zu tun hat, dass der Rest von dem, was da draußen ist, teilweise schon so grobe Scheiße ist, dass sie halt nicht gut funktioniert.
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, das ist auch der Hintergrund hinter diesem App-Signing und App-Store-Ding bei Apple.
Die werden das als Security-Maßnahmen verkaufen, natürlich.
Die möchten dann so und ja, aber Malware ist ja dann nicht signiert. Und das haben ja alle auch bei Microsoft gedacht, bis Stuxent kam.
Ja gut, also das Code-Signing gegen Malware hilft. Diese Legende, diese fürchte Apple wird ein Textbook-Example dafür werden, dass es irgendwie nicht funktioniert.
Apple muss das noch lernen. Aber Apple braucht ja sowieso immer ein bisschen länger, bis die Sachen lernen. Die haben ja auch so overflow-protection haben sie auch jahrelang nicht gebraucht.
Aber immerhin haben sie es jetzt in den Developer Guidelines drinstehen. Also das fand ich ja schon mal. Musstest du sogar loben, im Blog erwähnen, dass sie schrieben, dass es einfacher ist, es zu fixen, als irgendwie zu festzustellen, dass es nicht exploitbar ist.
In der Tat, das hat auch nur ungefähr 20 Jahre gedauert.
Na ja, aber immerhin. Microsoft hat es aber noch nicht in den Guidelines stehen.
Nicht?
Ich glaube nicht.
Also, keine Ahnung. Haben die überhaupt Guidelines?
Ich weiß nicht. Developer Guidelines würden sie doch wohl haben.
Müssen wir mal recherchieren.
Müssen wir mal gucken. Vielleicht hat sie einen höherer gesehen.
Vielleicht ist es in einer Euler. Unten im Kleinen gedruckt. Man hat irgendwie drei Stunden lang runtergerollt.
Ist der Euler vom Microsoft-Compiler?
Bitte schreiben Sie sicheren Code. Ja, das wäre geil, oder?
Das wäre cool.
This compiler may not be used to write insecure code.
Ja, naja. Also diese religiösen Elemente, die natürlich hier auch durchklingen hört, bei den Betriebssystems- und Computerwahlen, ist natürlich interessant, dass es zu so einer gewissen ersatzreligion geworden ist. Also gerade auch so, wenn du jetzt mal wieder so ein die-hard-Linux-Verfechter da vor der Flinte hast.
Na, das wird auch immer schwieriger, Linux zu vertreten, das wird alles immer schlimmer, diese ganzen scheißdistributionen. Das ist alles zum Heulen.
Was nehmen wir denn dann? Das ist alles Scheiße. Ich weiß, aber jeder sucht sich seinen Flavor von Scheiße aus.
Ich mach halt meine eigene Scheiße.
Aber bleibt dir übrig. Am Ende ist das Problem, was tue ich denn, wenn Apple jetzt so richtig scheiße geworden ist? Die Linux kann ich immer noch nicht benutzen.
Jetzt mal zu Windows. Hey, du hast inzwischen Windows-fähige Hardware am Start bei Apple gekauft. Ist doch gut.
Ich hab da leider nicht mal wieder versucht mit dem...
Nur, da funktioniert immerhin die H.264-Codec von Apple nicht mehr, diese QuickTime-Gülle.
Ach du herr, das wird man sich ja im Player-Gedächtchen... Ja. Ja, sind wir so weit am Ende?
Tja, so ist das.
Und dann...
Wir haben übrigens diesmal eine neue Aufnahmetechnik, vielleicht haben wir noch ein flatter Geld dann gekauft. Wir nehmen jetzt in 24-Bit-Sample-Tiefe auf und hoffen, dass man da mehr Dynamik am Ende raushört.
Ja, und hoffen, dass diese kleinen Probleme, die bisher immer noch bemängelt wurden, dass wir die damit behoben bekommen. Wir haben mit dem Gerät dann auch die Möglichkeit, bis zu sechs Gäste parallel noch mit jeweils dazuzufahren, also mit sechs Spuren parallel zu rekorden.
Wir haben glaube ich nicht bei allen Phantomspannungen am Start.
Doch, wir haben sechsmal Phantomspeisen am Start. Das war ja der Grund, dieses Gerät zu kaufen.
Und wir können auch noch eine E-Gitarre anschließen, wenn man will.
Ja, wenn wir den Erdgeist interviewen. Also kurz gesagt, wir hoffen, dass wir spätestens zum Kongress dann auch mal Alternativlos-Podcasts mit eingeladenen Gästen machen, zu bestimmten Themen. Das war so ein bisschen noch der Hintergrund für dieses Investment hier in dieser Hardware. Dank eurer Flatter-Spenden. Und um dann eben auch mal noch ein bisschen andere Perspektiven, nicht nur unsere dazu zu holen, obwohl unsere natürlich auch toll sind.
Unsere ist natürlich die Wichtigste, aber irgendwann sollen wir vielleicht auch mal andere reinholen, damit wir sie besser widerlegen können.
So, also dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wie gesagt, den Flatter-Knopf, den gibt es immer noch daneben. Wir sammeln gerade für die Headsets und Mikrofone für unsere Gäste, dann für die Interviews. Das ist dann unser nächster Aufrufsschritt.
Aber ansonsten sind wir natürlich durch mit den investitionen. Ach na ja, das geht immer ansonsten. Ja klar, wir können hier noch eine Platinverkleidung.
Naja, also der Rest wird dann einfach strategischen Eisbein investiert oder in tägliche Dinge.
Also es ist nicht so, dass wir das nicht ausgeben würden, wenn ihr mehr flattert als wir brauchen.
Wenn er flattert, dann geben wir es schon aus für gute Dinge.
Die größte Not für unsere Sachen sind eigentlich weg und jetzt kommen noch für Gäste rein. Und dann ist eigentlich das Ziel erstmal erreicht.
Dann machen wir Video oder so.
Genau, dann machen wir Video und kaufen hier noch Kameras und richten ein studio ein und...
Gut, dann...
Ich hoffe, es hat euch wieder Spaß gemacht.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören, wie schon gesagt und bis zum nächsten Mal.